Wenn bei Fernseh-Gewinnspielen wieder die Frage gestellt wird, wer Fußballer ist, Franz Beckenbauer oder Donald Duck, rufen sie an, faxen sie, mailen sie, schicken sie eine SMS mit der Antwort Donald Duck. Donald Duck natürlich, wer sonst? Überfluten sie den Sender mit der Antwort Donald Duck, bis er zusammenbricht, bis die Redakteure wahnsinnig werden und sich aus den Fenstern stürzen. Antworten sie überhaupt auf jede Frage, nur noch mit Donald Duck. Außer natürlich, wenn nach Donald Duck gefragt wird. Bringen sie dieses Gebäude, in dem wir tot gehalten werden, zum Einsturz. Und wenn Politiker Abscheu und Empörung äußern bei der Hinrichtung unschuldiger Geiseln, überschütten sie alle Zeitungen mit jubelnden Leserbriefen. Hurra, die Schweine sind tot! Bis sich die Journalisten erbrechen, das eigene Papier auffressen und daran ersticken. Wer hat gesagt, dass wir die Welt nicht ändern können? Wir können die Welt ändern. Gewaltlos, respektlos und ohne Taktgefühl für den Rhythmus der Vernichter. Werden Sie Situationist und passen Sie endlich nirgendwo mehr hinein, aber gut auf alles auf.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 185. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ihr habt lange warten müssen auf diese Ausgabe. Vieles hat sich ergeben, nur keine Gelegenheit hier waren wieder eine neue Sendung aufzunehmen. Ich erspare euch die Gründe und Ausführungen, warum das alles so hat sein müssen. Tatsache ist, ich hab's geschafft mal wieder eine interessante Runde zusammenzutrommeln und auch ein entsprechend interessantes Thema, wie ich finde. Was ich auch schon ganz lange auf meiner Liste habe, meiner geheimen kleinen Liste von wundersamen Themen. Und ich hab heute auch gleich zwei Gäste zu Gast. Und zwar Abdullah und Karl. Und ihr seid ein Teil des Universums, das da heißt, Hedonistische Internationale. Hab ich das gut getroffen?
Wir sind Vertreter der Berlin-Sektion, der Sektion Berlin.
Ja, wie viele Sektionen gibt es denn?
Ich glaube, der letzte Stand, ich weiß nicht genau, das waren über 60. Und die gibt es mittlerweile. Eine der letzten, die sich gegründet hat, war in den USA, in Minnesota. Die wurden auch gleich übel zusammengeknüppelt, als sie dann mit Soundsystemen irgendwie auf die Straße sind.
Ich behaupte, es gibt natürlich noch hunderte und tausende von unentdeckten Sektionen, die dann irgendwann in Erscheinung treten können.
Ja, also das ist jetzt sozusagen tatsächlich so, dass die Hedonistische Internationale auch wirklich sich schon Internationale nennen darf. Aber angefangen hat es doch schon in Berlin.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Es hat angefangen in Berlin. Aber es gab dann relativ schnell auch Leute, die dann das in der Schweiz gemacht haben, in Zürich. Die waren irgendwie auch das Schweizer-Tum auf den Arm genommen, also eher so Sachen gemacht, wie mit großen Schweizer fahren durch die Gegend und diese Wander-Geschichten gemacht und dann auch mit Grammophonen in Altersheime und so. Also so eine komische Traditionalisten-Satire. Also dann war es eigentlich international.
Also wenn ich mich nicht rechnen will, gab es da ganz am Anfang die Sektion Gullo Alvento in Italien.
Stimmt.
Das waren die Leute, die ihren Gullo, ihren Hintern, an den Wind halten wollten, an die Luft. Gullo Alvento hat uns auch gleich von Anfang an bestärkt, die waren innerhalb von kürzester Zeit mit dabei. Das fand ich aber seitdem nie wieder gekettet.
Macht ihr das auch?
Das machen wir durchaus. Das ist legitim und auch beliebt, denn Hintern im Wind funktionieren generell immer, egal ob gegen Nazis, also immer. Das ist natürlich eine Frage.
Ich würde sagen, das ist eins der beständigsten PR-Techniken und Kommunikationstechniken, um Aufmerksamkeit zu erregen. Geht seit Ewigkeiten. Hat 68 schon geklappt, klappt immer noch und man kriegt immer dafür Presse. Also bringt immer Aufmerksamkeit und ist nützlich, um zum Beispiel Nazi-Kleiden zu stürmen.
Oder zu teure Mietwohnungen oder Verkaufsobjekte. Das hat alles schon geklappt. Das haben wir auch alles schon gemacht bzw. verschiedene andere. Man muss betonen, wir haben oft selber nicht genau im Blick, was so alles in der Berlin geschweige denn in anderen Sektionen passiert. Denn wir sind als Hedonistische Internationale eine Idee und das ganze Prinzip beruht darauf, Sektionen zu gründen.
Vielleicht müsst ihr erst mal kurz erläutern, was ist die Hedonistische Internationale? Gibt es irgendwie eine offizielle Definition oder wird das auch im Unklagen gelassen?
Es gibt glaube ich keine offizielle Definition. Was es gibt, ist ein Manifest in verschiedenen Sprachen und da steht überall hoffentlich das gleiche drin, wenn die Leute richtig übersetzt haben. Und dieses Manifest macht irgendwie so ungefähr klar, um was es geht und setzt auch einen Handlungsrahmen so ein bisschen. Und anhand dieses Manifests kann ich dann sagen, anhand dieser Idee, okay, bin auch eine Sektion oder wir sind auch eine Sektion und kann das dann einfach auf der Webseite ankündigen. Und ich glaube ja immer erst dran, wenn eine Aktion passiert, dass es die auch wirklich gibt, aber das ist das Prinzip. Also ich kann sagen, mir gefällt das Manifest, ich will in Aktion treten, ich mach mit und dann machen die Leute auch einfach.
Grundsätzlich kann man sagen, behaupte ich mal, entstand die Hedonistische Internationale aus dem eigenen Gefühl, dass man wahnsinnig viele schöne und spaßige Sachen machen kann und Bilder prägen kann der Öffentlichkeit in den Medien und eigene Bilder oder die Wahrheit, die wahren Bilder zeichnen kann. Und dass man dafür auch Pseudonymität und einen gewissen Schutz braucht. Und das bietet die Hedonistische Internationale hoffentlich innerhalb von Sektionen, wenn man eine gute Idee hat, wenn man gerade einen Geistesblitz hat und sagt, da muss ich jetzt unbedingt was machen, das Problem, ein politisches, gesellschaftliches Problem brennt mir auf den Nägeln, unter den Nägeln, ich muss was tun, dann kannst du da mit einer Sektion eingreifen. Und ja, das entwickelt sich tatsächlich auch ganz prächtig.
Wie ist das denn überhaupt dazu gekommen? Also wann hat sich die HI so gegründet?
Also es gab davor schon Aktionen, die so ähnlich waren, also auch aus dem Dunstkreis, so Sachen. Und das hat sich dann irgendwann, war das 2006, kam irgendwie raus, dass Nazis ziemlich viele Übergriffe gemacht haben in Friedrichshain und dann hat sich eine, wie hieß das noch, Initiative für hedonistische Stadtentwicklung und, naja, der Name, der war noch länger, der war auf jeden Fall total komplizierter Name, haben dann eine Demo gemacht mit viel Musik und 3000 Leuten und daraus ist dann später irgendwann die hedonistische Internationale gegründet worden. Ich glaube zum G8-Gipfel dann in Heiligendamm.
Wobei ich natürlich grundsätzlich behaupte, das gibt es seit Epikur, seit 2500 Jahren ungefähr oder 2300 Jahren, seit Epikur dem Philosophen, der den Hedonismus begründet hat.
Ach, der war das.
Und dann ist es natürlich auch einfach der Name Hedonismus. Natürlich, also das ist auch ein Kampfbegriff gegen uns, denke ich. Wie das so oft ist bei sozialen Bewegungen, man nimmt den Kampfbegriff der Kritiker und sagt, also sogar ein guter Freund, ein Bekannter von uns meinte irgendwann, ihr seid ja diese Anarcho-Hedonisten.
Das meint der in Genua, bei dem G8-Gipfel Genua. Nachdem wir da irgendwie das eher spaßmäßig gesehen haben, was dann nicht mehr ging, nachdem dann Leute erschossen wurden und so. Aber am Anfang meinte er, ihr seid doch voll die Anarcho-Hedonisten. Und der hat es eigentlich auch mitgeprägt.
Da wart ihr in Genua.
Ich war da.
Und hast da so mit demonstriert. Aber du hast erstmal keine besondere Aktion gemacht.
Nee, da war ich gerade so. Aber ich glaube, ich war immer schon irgendwie, fand ich es wichtig, dass das...
Aber diese Genua-Demonstration hat er als Spaßaktion schon gewertet?
Ein anderer, der meinte, weil wir das eher nicht so ernst und verbissen gesehen haben. Ich glaube, es war immer so ein Ding, Politik nicht so komplett ernst und verbissen zu sehen, sondern das Ganze spielerisch zu machen und mit Spaß da ranzugehen und auch Spaß an Aktionen zu haben. Was in Genua schwierig wurde dann, das war so brutal von der italienischen Polizei.
Aber generell, was die Antifa oder die Anti-Deutschen oder andere Linkegruppen oder auch Parteien nicht schaffen konnten, war zum Beispiel mich einfach einzubinden und zu begeistern, weil da ganz schnell dieses Moralinsaure in der Luft hing, die Vorwürfe, egal ob sie jetzt, also Richtungsdiskussionen unnötigerweise.
Das sind Vorwürfe, dass man irgendwie sei.
Dass man irgendwie sei oder irgendwie sein muss. Das Label-Denken. Im Großen und Ganzen. Ich denke, um dem Label zu entkommen, haben wir das Label gemacht. Unsere eigenen selber eins gegeben.
Also Hedonistische Internationale ist sozusagen ein Nicht-Label.
Ein Stück, weil mittlerweile ist es auch zum Label-Label geworden. Das ist manchmal schon fast bedenklich, finde ich. Man sollte mal wieder den Namen wechseln. Im Großen und Ganzen. Also für mich jedenfalls, und ich denke, das ist für jeden persönlich auch noch mal ein eigenes Ding, aber für mich hat es was davon. Für Label gibt es Labelmanager. Und wir haben uns etwas einfallen lassen, damit wir Pseudonym, anonymen, wenn du so willst, aber pseudonym Dinge tun können und regelverletzende Dinge vielleicht auch tun können.
Aber du siehst es schon irgendwie so links verortet.
Ja, aber es war immer eigentlich als offenes Ding gedacht. Deswegen ist auch ein Label, wenn ich sage, ich bin jetzt Hedonist von der Hedonistischen International, würde ich von mir nie so sagen wollen, weil ich glaube, das grenzt das auch schon wieder ein. Und ich fand immer die Stärke von diesem ganzen Projekt, von der Idee, war, dass es ganz verschiedene Leute gab, die da auf einmal das mitgemacht haben. Und deswegen finde ich es auch richtig, dass es nicht so kanalisiert ist, sondern dass es sehr viel Anschluss fähig ist zu Technoszenen, Leute, die manchmal vielleicht unpolitisch waren, bis zu Linksradikalen. Und das ist so ein bisschen diffuse. Und ich finde, jedes Label macht ein, und deswegen sollte es eigentlich diffus bleiben. Weil dann können Leute damit arbeiten, sagen, ich mache da jetzt eine Sektion und baue damit irgendwie ein bisschen Scheiße, Chaos oder eine schöne Aktion oder was auch immer.
Also darauf nochmal zu antworten. Links, ja, also das kommt drauf an, also ich bin jetzt nicht wie die Piraten und sage, wir sind nicht links und nicht rechts, wir sind vorne, das halte ich für albern. Wenn man ein Stück weit gesellschaftskritisch unterwegs ist und dort sich aktiv bewegt und denkt, dann ist das für mich was Linkes. Und in der Hinsicht, würde ich sagen, ist das für mich ein linkes Projekt. Aber durchaus auch in dem Sinne, dass man eben das als einen Prozess versteht. Dieses Prozess hat, du kommst damit zum Ausdruck, dass du erstmal von den Hierarchien Abstand nimmst und die sind mit Labeln und mit ersten und zweiten Sprechern und dem ganzen üblichen Prämborium verbunden, was du auch in Parteien und in anderen Situationen vorfindest.
Auch bei der Antifa?
Auch bei denen und erst recht natürlich. Also das ist schon so. Ich möchte mich gar nicht so sehr von denen abgrenzen, denn da haben wir viele gute Freunde und wir haben immer wahnsinnig viel Spaß mit denen auch zusammen gehabt und die haben sich auch immer gefreut, dass wir Spaß mit denen hatten. Und das ist natürlich was, was mit dazu gehört. Aber ich persönlich, also ich persönlich würde nie sagen, ich bin Antifa. Das ist halt auch wieder eine fast schon ideologische Verengung. Und wozu?
Na gut, aber ich lese ja raus, ihr fühltet euch jetzt nicht so wohl in den anderen Gruppierungen, weil die sich eigentlich viel zu sehr organisieren.
Aber nein, das ist, ich glaube, ich habe mich nie wohl gefühlt in Sachen, die dich dann verengen. Also ich wurde mal auf irgendeiner Demo, war irgendeine Hausbesetzer-Demo gefragt, warum hast du dich nicht schwarz angezogen? Und ich fand, ich meine, ich sitze jetzt im schwarzen Bulli oder so. Aber ich fand das total bescheuert. Also das ist eine Uniformierung. Ich habe nicht Bock, mich schwarz anzuziehen und irgendwie dann mache ich das. Aber ich habe einfach keine Lust, irgendwie so ein Label, du bist autonomer, wenn du einen schwarzen Glover an hast.
Wo kommen wir denn da hin, wenn im schwarzen Block die Leute auf einmal ihre T-Shirts tragen?
Wobei man sagen muss, zu dem, was wir tun oder gemacht haben, zu diesen Sponti-Aktionen kann man ja auch sagen, zu diesen Prägen von Situationen in der Öffentlichkeit gehört auch ein Maß an Organisation und technischem Know-how. Und da tragen wir allerdings aus verschiedensten Richtungen immer wieder kompetente Leute zusammen oder die kommen zu uns und machen auch was. Das ist ganz praktisch. Das ist eine Mischung aus Hightech und Lowtech. Und dann halt noch, was ist es denn, das Spüren für die richtige Situation, in der man was machen kann.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, diese Gründungsphase war das jetzt einfach so, ihr wurdet als, was war das, Spaß, nie als Nacho-Hedonisten bezeichnet und damit war sozusagen die Idee geboren, sich dann diesen Schuh einfach anzuziehen.
Nee, ich glaube, es kam eher aus so einer Sache heraus, dass wir so immer schon Lust hatten, eben spaßige Aktionen zu machen. Und das war dann, so ein Vorläufer war diese Promilitär-Demonstration. Mehr Krieg für alle. Also wir hatten erst eine Bündnisverantwortung jetzt gegründet, dass die Bundesregierung, es war eher so auf so einem Menschenrechtsimperialistischen Duktus, also wir müssen da für Menschenrechte kämpfen, deswegen müsste die Bundesregierung auch im Irak dabei sein. Das war als Schröder damals, da man sagt, wir machen da nicht mit, obwohl natürlich die Flugzeuge über Deutschland geflogen sind. Und dann hatten wir erst diese Initiative, hatten es aber dann nur geschafft, die junge Welt zu verarschen. Die sagten, da gibt es jetzt auch eine Gruppe, die wollen da für Krieg eintreten und haben dann den militärischen Arm gegründet, die Initiative Mehr Krieg für alle.
Das klappte ganz gut. Also es war eine Choreografie eigentlich. Also wir haben gesagt, also eigentlich die Stimmung ist doch so, dass wir jetzt eigentlich, was sollen wir jetzt wieder, wie alle weltweit gegen Krieg sein. Wir müssen jetzt, also jetzt hier, Deutsche an die Front endlich Verantwortung in der Welt wieder übernehmen. Und das hat uns so viel Spaß gemacht, das auch durchzudenken, dass wir dann eben Verantwortung jetzt übernehmen wollten.
Die Webseite gibt es glaube ich noch, schöner-krieg.fk, da ist ein herrlicher Aufruf. Das ist ja so der militärische Arm, da gibt es auch einen Onlineshop für Schurkenstaaten und so drauf. Und das war eine richtige Kampagne. Das ging also soweit, dass dann Jubeln bis der Krieg kommt, Plakate irgendwie ins Netz gesetzt mit amerikanische Botschafter und wir jubeln ihnen, dann haben die abgesagt und ich weiß nicht, was kann es noch? Manöver auf dem bocksagenden Platz?
Manöver auf dem bocksagenden Platz, woraufhin wir da Reclaim the Street, Join the Army gemacht hatten, werden auf einmal Hundertschaften dort stehen, weil Reclaim the Streets da mit dabei waren. Die armen Punks, die kamen, ich entschuldige mich heute noch bei ihnen, die dann, wir sind natürlich nicht gekommen, aber da kamen Leute in Uniform. Wir hatten geauftragt, sie ziel euch eure Uniformen an, marschgeeigende Bekleidung, weil wir durften ja auch bei der Demonstration dann nicht sagen, wie sie es haben.
Ich sehe hier gerade auf, da beziehe ich mich richtig zu Demo.
Ja, so was, ist eigentlich einfach. Und das Internet war, glaube ich, noch ein Stückchen jünger. Das heißt, du konntest mit so was damals, vor ungefähr zehn Jahren, ja, noch eine riesige Welle auslösen, weil die Leute, also die Angst, dass so was übers Netz unkontrolliert, über sich verbreitet, war, glaube ich, noch größer. Und das klappte daher ganz hervorragend.
Aber ja, auf jeden Fall war das lustig. Also am Tag bevor dann hier in Berlin 700.000 Leute gegen Krieg demonstriert haben, sind dann 400 Uniformierte vom Bundesverteidigungsministerium.
Ich sehe gerade die Plakate, endlich noch mehr Krieg. Jubel über den Krieg, die große Kriegsbegeisterungsdemo. Oder auch Töten für den Frieden, ich bin dabei.
Das hat sich ja auch bewahrheitet. Also das Schlimme ist, man kann tatsächlich ja oft die Realität nicht mehr ad absurdum fühlen. Das klappte damals, aber im Zweifelsfall ist ja genau das politisch auch verfolgt worden. Das sind unsere Interessen am Hindukusch. Das wird getötet für den Frieden.
Das ist natürlich ein generelles Problem, dass die Realität noch viel hedonistischer wäre sicherlich die falsche Bezeichnung. Aber dass sie so albern verzerrt teilweise wirkt, dass man gar nicht in der Lage ist, es noch weiter zu verzerren.
Das gibt es auch. Das ist durchaus schwierig. Zum Beispiel gab es eine Sektion, die hatte gerade beim Papstbesuch was gemacht. Die haben sich als total super Fundamentalisten in Weiß und haben da irgendwie eine Aktion gemacht. Das ist teilweise nicht aufgefallen. Da kamen dann Opus Dei-Priester und gingen, ja gut, hier die frommen jungen Leute und so. Dann kannst du das gar nicht mehr überzeichnen. Die hatten einen Haufen Spaß davor im Olympiastadion.
Die wälzten sich zu Soffen in Weißen Gewändern am Boden und wurden trotzdem von Nonnen umarmt. Da ist es natürlich schwer. Das liegt aber auch ein bisschen daran, man muss sich halt die Situation suchen. Sie wurden auch von der Polizei durchgelassen, weil sie halt authentisch wirkten. Also natürlich im religiösen fundamentalistischen Wahn fällst du nicht mehr auf, weil du als fundamentalist kommst. Das ist klar.
Oh Mann. Also ja, das ist schon so ein Spiel. Wie schaffst du es mit dem Überzeichnen? Also selbst bei diesen Pro-Kriegs-Aktionen, wir haben dann irgendwie mit so Holzkalaschnikows auf der Warschauer Brücke in Berlin, haben dann so Unterschriften mit so Trag dich ein für den Krieg. Und da kamen dann Leute, wie könnt ihr für Krieg sein? Und haben uns das wirklich dann empört angegriffen, obwohl es natürlich total lächerlich ist, mit einer Press-Span Kalaschnikow in der Hand und so einer Klade. Und willst du nach Irak oder nach Venezuela?
Auf der einen oder anderen Seite war das eines der wenigen Male, wo ich wirklich offensiv dann also ein politisches Bekenntnis abgelegt habe.
Ich will noch so ein bisschen in der Geschichte rumstorren und vor allem auch so ein bisschen in den Hintergrund. Ich meine, so Hedonismus, du hast es ja schon erwähnt, das ist ja so altes Zeug irgendwie aus Griechenland. Da geht es halt um, was ist denn eure Definition von Hedonismus? Also Lust, ja, sinnliche Begierde, wie seht ihr das?
Lust und Genuss, und es ist natürlich eine selbstbezogene Idee, eine politische Idee, die sagt, es geht erstmal auch um mich und um meinen Lust und Genuss und Vermeidung von Schmerz. Das bringt sehr viel Freiheit mit sich. Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein zentraler Begriff in der ganzen Hedonistischen Internationale. Es geht viel um Freiheit. Es geht aber auch nicht um so einen Egoismus, ich mache, was ich will. Sondern irgendwie ist er schon dabei zu sehen, ich mache, was ich will, aber mit anderen zusammen. Und nur zusammen kann das dann auch irgendwie wirklich Freude machen. Also nur ich alleine ist irgendwie langweilig.
Wobei das die Umkehrung des Kampfbegriffes ist. Normalerweise in der Soziologie werden Hedonistische Schichten, soweit ich das im Blick habe, als die Dinosgruppe Hedonismus. Die werden als die bezeichnet, die eigentlich nur vom Fernseher sitzen, Bier trinken und gucken, wo sie bleiben. Und wir haben das eigentlich, und das glaube ich, kann man an der jüngeren Begriffsgeschichte sozusagen jedenfalls in den Magazinen und Zeitungen sehen, ein Stück weit umgedeutet, dass das auch was anderes bedeuten kann.
Sinusgruppe ist so ein Marketingbegriff. Das ist so die Sinusgruppe. Das ist eher so untere Mittelschicht, die geht nur arbeiten, damit sie dann Spaß haben kann und konsumieren kann, interessiert sich nicht für Politik.
Warum Sinus?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum die machen das.
Weil die jetzt so mitschwingen oder weil die immer so arbeiten?
Es gibt auch Sinusgruppe Performer. Oder was ist ich?
Keine Ahnung.
Es gibt so ein Schaubild. Da war das die Idee, das auch zu sagen, Lust und Genuss und Freude zu haben, ist eine Sache, die eint sehr viele Menschen. Und das nicht nur auf so einen materialistischen, komischen Spaßgesellschaftsbegriff zu reduzieren.
Ein positiver, freudiger Ansatz, auch ein mutiger Ansatz, um gesellschaftlich aktiv zu werden. Ich denke, das trifft es. Und da kann man sich auch leicht eingliedern.
Und ausgliedern.
Und auch wieder ausgliedern, das ist auch ganz wichtig.
Okay, ihr habt das ja hier eigentlich in diesem Manifest auch niedergeschrieben. Hier die Hedonistische Internationale will Freude, Lust, Genuss und ein selbstbestimmtes Leben in Freiheit für alle Menschen. Das ist ja schon mal ein sehr honoriges Ziel. Sie tätet Hedonismus nicht als Motor einer dumpfen, materialistischen Spaßgesellschaft, sondern als Chance zur Überwindung des Bestehenden. Also es ist schon Revolution.
Ja, aber eben nicht unter so einem...
Also es ist nicht die blutige Revolution, sondern es ist da schon auf Bewusstseinswandel angelegt. Jedenfalls habe ich das immer so verstanden. Es ist allerdings auch verdammt lang her, dass ich das geschrieben wurde. Merke ich jetzt gerade so. Auf der anderen Seite natürlich, also wenn ich mich befrage, finde ich diese Utopien, die da drin sind gut, ja, sage ich sofort, ja, klar. Gutes Leben für alle Menschen. Ich meine, das sind ja eigentlich UN-Ziele. Also da ist eigentlich nichts gegen einzubinden.
Ja, das kann ich auch nur voll unterstreichen. Aber du hast ja auch schon andere Vorbilder eben genannt. Oder ich weiß nicht, ob Sie das als Vorbilder angehören, aber so diese Sponti-Bewegung, so der 68er, war das schon... Ist das vergleichbar?
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Das ist ja auch politisch motiviert.
Ich glaube, das ist in fast jeder Bewegung, zumindest in neueren, gab es immer auch die Leute, die mit Spaß an der Sache waren und das Ganze nicht mit der Roten-Mau-Bibel unterm Kopf gesehen haben. Und in so einer Tradition stehen wir sicher irgendwie. Aber ich glaube, da gibt es auch immer wieder Ideen. Und es gibt wunderbare Bücher, die man lesen kann. Und diese ganzen Sachen tauchen auch in neuer Form wieder auf.
Also ich erinnere mich, dass ich lange lachend vom Rechner saß, als diese Ideen entstanden. Und wir Wikipedia-Artikel über die Situationisten lasen, eine Künstlergruppe aus Frankreich. Und da gab es eine Aktion von einem Weihnachtsmann, der an Weihnachten sich verkleidet hat, in den Supermarkt gegangen war, in eine Spielzeug-Abteilung, und dort an Kinder anfingen, die Spielsachen zu verschenken. Und diese Idee fand ich großartig. Die wurden natürlich dann irgendwann festgenommen, aber die Kinder durften die Geschenke behalten.
Nee, die mussten sie auch abgeben und das ganze Bild fliegt zusammen.
Vielleicht lag es auch am Einfluss gewisser Medikamente.
Ich hab mich kaputt gelacht für Stunden.
Und das war schon der Geist, den ich in Aktionen, wenn man sie selber macht, eigentlich wiederfinden will. Das ist das, wo man halt lacht und die Leute, die das sehen, erkennen, man macht ja eigentlich was Wahres. Man bricht, es muss nicht unbedingt antikonsumistisch sein, man bricht bestehende Normen. Und dadurch kommen andere Wahrheiten zutage. Das ist eigentlich kein neues Prinzip, ein altes Prinzip, ein satirisches Prinzip ganz oft auch. Und das tut auch oft weh. Man merkt das auch, deswegen sind wir auch immer Pseudonymen unterwegs. Dafür gibt es viel Kritik. Und man wird, glaube ich, auch von bestehenden Institutionen dafür immer zumindest als potenzielles Risiko gesehen. Das ist, glaube ich, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber vielleicht auch als Risiko.
Warum? Na ja, man scheint ja die bestehende Ordnung nicht so zu akzeptieren, nicht als Normalität zu akzeptieren. Und je nachdem, welche Form von Aktion es ist, ist das schmerzhaft. Das ist vielleicht geschäftsschädigend, vielleicht ist es rufschädigend, je nachdem, ob es Politik oder Wirtschaft ist oder eine Institution. Und das ist wahrscheinlich schon genug, um das abzulehnen oder vielleicht sogar zu verfolgen, zu überwachen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, da weiß ich nicht genau. Aber das Wichtigste ist, da nicht die Spielregeln zu spielen. Ich meine, du wurdest mal auf dieser Flughafenbesetzungsaktion hier Tempelhof übelst angriffen. Wir hatten ein Anti-Konflikteam gemacht, unabhängig. Wir hatten Southern Comfort-Schirmmützen und auch so blöde Neon-Dingern. Das Oha-Team, Offenheit, Hedonismus und Anarchie. Die Polizei-Version ist AHA, Aufmerksamkeit, Hilfe, Appell. Und wir hatten auch ein eigenes Anti-Konflikteam, haben immer die aggressivsten Polizisten angesprochen. Sagt, verstehe ja, dass sie hier ihren Einsatz machen müssen. Also genau die gleiche Tour.
Sehen Sie doch ein, es hat doch keinen Sinn, dass Sie hier stehen.
Und dafür haben Sie ihn richtig mit Pfefferspray, also sich haben Sie ja richtig fertig gemacht.
Ach so, ihr habt auf die Sicherheitsleute eingeredet.
Auf die schlimmsten, aggressivsten Polizisten. So wie das Anti-Konflikteam ja auch versucht, vor dem Konflikt einzugreifen. Dann gehen Sie doch nach Hause. Sie wissen, Sie machen jetzt hier eine Ordnungswidrigkeit, wenn Sie hier weiter da bleiben. Wir werden dann Zwang gegen Sie einsetzen müssen. Und genau so hatte eben diese Sektion, dieses unabhängige Konflikteam auch Bücher gelesen, Polizeischulungsbücher, wie das funktioniert. Und diese Strategie angewendet auf Sie. Und das ist halt, ich glaube, die werden immer nervös, wenn nicht nach den Spielregeln. Die normale Spielregel ist, ich greife da irgendwie an und bin Demonstrant und dann wird gerangelt. Und wenn ich irgendwie anders reingehe, da können sie schwer mit umgehen. Und im Zweifelsfall kriegt man dann...
Das gilt aber nicht nur für die Polizei, jetzt die Exekutive auf der Straße, sondern das gilt generell. Aber bei der Polizei muss man sich natürlich auch nicht wundern, wenn man dann dort sozusagen als Störer, als Störer in ihren Augen, obwohl ich natürlich sehr friedlich war, erkannt und dann auch dementsprechend behandelt wird. Das war tatsächlich eine Behandlung, die ich erfahren habe. Nicht als einziger dort, aber das ist gut.
Spaß-Gerillia, das ist ja auch so ein Wort, das ist schon ein bisschen Gerillia-Methoden, dass man einfach ein anderes Kampfverhalten an den Tag legt, als es der andere erwartet, was dann auch zu einer besonderen Verstörung führt, oder dass man auch komplett unter dem Radar bleibt.
Ja, ich glaube auf jeden Fall, wir haben ja keine Mittel. Wir haben eigentlich nie Geld für Aktionen. Und die anderen haben ja immer, der Gegner hat immer mehr Geld. Von dem her ist es schon mal dieses Ungleichgewicht. Und dann ein Gegner mit ganz... Einfaches Beispiel war dieses, du setzt eine Fotomontage ins Internet und der Botschafter spricht nicht. Also es ist ein billiges Beispiel, aber das ist natürlich sehr einfach. Es hat eine Viertelstunde gedauert, auf Photoshop das zu bearbeiten.
Konkret, was war das?
Das war auch bei diesem Antikrieg, bei diesem alten Ding. Auch einfach nur das Plakat, das Offizielle, der Botschaft, der US-Botschaft genommen. Ein bisschen den Text geändert. Und das in die Media geladen. Hat dazu geführt, dass sie absagen vor Panik. Weil sie denken, da ist irgendwie was.
Was habt ihr denn da drauf gestellt?
Botschaft oder Weckklatschen?
Nein, nein, nein. Ein Halschopf, so war es so aggressiv. Jubeln, bis der Krieg kommt, für patriotische Begeisterung wird gesorgt.
Bei Weckklatschen hätten wir nie mehr gesagt. Also zur Gewalt, zur Gewalt. Zur Gewalt hätten wir nicht aufgerufen.
Und das reicht aus. Und das ist schon eine guerrille Methode, wenn ich mit ganz einfachem Mittel ich hätte, könnte auch Andro und ich machen da Feuer und Flamme dem Botschafter. Das wäre jetzt die andere Rente. Hat aber den gleichen Effekt, dann sagen sie auch ab.
Ja, das ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, eine beliebte Strategie, dass man so die Medien und Signets, Logos, Zeichen, auch vor allem Hoheitszeichen der anderen nimmt und dann einfach geringfügig ändert. Das funktioniert ja auch so in der Markenwelt, nicht wahr, so dieses Ad-Busting, was dann eben so diese total etablierten, eingefahrenen Logos nimmt, die jeder einfach kennt und sofort wegspeichert. Und dann macht man einfach so kleine Änderungen, die so subtil sind, dass vielleicht von manchen nicht wahrgenommen werden, aber natürlich in dem Moment, wo sie wirklich verstanden werden, dann auch einen besonderen Humor in sich tragen.
Also Prinzip bei uns, es war oft die Überaffirmation. Das heißt also, wie Jubeln für den Krieg und noch mehr Krieg für alle, endlich dürfen wir wieder. Jetzt bleiben wir ein bisschen immer bei diesem Kriegsbeispiel, aber das macht ziemlich viel klar. Diese Überaffirmation ist natürlich eine Waffe, indem man das so sehr zuspitzt, wie gesagt, dass den Leuten, die es lesen, erstmal nicht klar ist, ob es jetzt wahr ist oder nicht. Eigentlich ist es toll, wenn du Dementis bekommst von den jeweiligen Stellen, das ist immer super. Oder wenn du wirklich Empörung bekommst von Leuten, die eigentlich schon in deinem Sinne denken. Das ist auch nicht schlecht, weil dann hast du ziemlich viel geschafft. Da muss man natürlich freut sich sein, bei welchem Thema man wie weit geht. Ich denke, da habe ich viel Vertrauen in die Menschen, die dann Sektionen gründen, dass die das hinkriegen.
Alle arbeiten auf eigene Karte, ne?
Also die Sektionen sind alle selbst für ihre Aktionen verantwortlich. Also wenn es dann halt mal Ärger gibt, so wie irgendwann mal Hannover, da gab es auch, die haben eine Straßenbahnparty gemacht, die es dann eskaliert und dann gab es auch eine, das war auch eine lustige Geschichte, eine kleine Anfrage, dass der irgendwie im Landesparlament in Niedersachsen, wer oder was ist die Hedonistische Internationale? Die haben dann den Wikipedia-Artikel genommen, der ist im Ministerium, hat gesagt, das ist die Hedonistische Internationale als Antwort auf die kleine Anfrage.
Wer hat die denn gestellt?
Irgendein politischer Oppositionspolitiker.
Muss das nicht eine Fraktion machen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung über die niedersächsische Landespolitik, aber das gibt es noch irgendwo im Netz. Auf jeden Fall, wann ich das losse, da ist das auf eigene Kappe.
Also die Antwort der Regierung war ein Wikipedia-Artikel, den wir selbst geschrieben.
Haben. Die Sektionen sind selbstverantwortlich. Das ist ja eine Idee und ich kann sagen, ich bin jetzt eine Sektion. Und dann machen Leute irgendwas. Das kann ja nicht einen zentralen Verantwortlichen geben. Das gibt es auf gar keinen Fall. Das ist alles unabhängig. Die machen, was sie wollen.
Was habt ihr denn bei dieser G8 gemacht? Das fiel ja vorhin, dass es sich das erste Mal so richtig manifestiert hat. Was kann man denn auf so einer Demo, wo alles total hektisch ist und draußen machen?
Wir haben dort ein eigenes Camp errichtet, neben dem offiziellen Camp, wo es auch Musik gab und so. Wir haben irgendwie mit anderen Leuten zusammen einen 5 Meter Durchmesser-Pinkenball an die Blockaden gefahren. Das war so aus Luftballons und so Stretchfolie. Das war ein Projekt von Leuten, wir haben die unterstützt und sind da hingefahren. Das wurde dann beschlagnahmt. Das habe ich heute noch zu Hause, das denke ich. Das ist wunderschöne Beschlagnahmungsurkunde. Aus gefahren abwährenden Gründen wird beschlagnahmt. 2.000 pinke Luftballons in Stretchfolie eingewickelt beschlagnahmt. Das war die Idee, spielerisch mit diesem Ball an den Blockaden irgendwas zu machen. Gibt es auch ein Video? Das ist eine schöne Wahl.
Ich erinnere mich aber auch, dass wir damals erfahren haben, welche Macht es hat, tatsächlich friedlich, mit lauter Musik, mit großen Bässen vor allem, in schwierige Situationen hineinzufahren. Da gab es eine hochkritische Situation. Die Polizei auf der einen Seite, der Schwarze Block auf der anderen Seite. Und es war kurz vorm Eskalieren. Und wir fuhren damals mit einem riesigen Truck, mit einem alten Feuerwehrwagen, mit riesigen Bässen da rein. Und die Leute fingen an zu tanzen. Das deeskalierte tatsächlich, aber durchaus im positiven Sinne. Also weder die Polizei hatte ihren Spaß noch der Schwarze Block. Entschuldigung. Aber es war natürlich trotzdem ein wahnsinniges Bild auch. Das hat was zu dem Charakter von diesem doch sehr friedlichen Gipfel in Heiligendamm beigetragen. Das ist so ein Puzzleteil von vielen, wo man sagt, okay, das ändert den Charakter einer Demonstration vielleicht auch.
Da sind doch auch so Leute als Clowns rumgelaufen auf der Veranstaltung.
Die immer die Polizei so nachgemacht haben, sich so nebendran stellen. Und auch diese Polizeihaltung und das eben auf die Schippe nehmen. Die sind nicht von uns.
Die waren aber unrelated. Aber im Prinzip haben die dasselbe Ding da exerziert, oder?
Das ist eine mutige Arbeit. Die machen natürlich irgendwas viel Mutigeres. Die gehen wirklich so direkt an die Polizei ran und veräppeln die. Das ist sehr ähnlich vom Ansatz her.
Die heißen aber anders. Das ist die Clowns Army. Intergalactic Clowns Army oder irgendwas. Ja, ähnliches Prinzip auf jeden Fall.
Ich erinnere mich aber auch, dass das Camp zum Sammelbecken für verschiedenste Leute wurde, zum Beispiel für Franzosen, die mit Gabba, wir nannten sie dann die Gabba-Franzosen, die kamen dann auf unser Besetztes Camp, weil sie sonst nirgendwo ankamen und mehrfach durchsucht worden waren. Und das war eine Herausforderung, denn diese Gabba-Franzosen waren hoch strukturiert organisiert und haben die ganze Nacht Gabba gespielt. Das war neben dem Attack-Camp, neben dem wir damals waren, eigentlich ganz nett.
Echt, Gabba, das gibt's noch?
Bei denen gab's das noch. Auf jeden Fall mit DJs, die hinter großen Wänden standen, damit man sie nicht sehen kann, damit da überhaupt gar nicht erst ein DJ-Kult entstehen kann. Das fand ich auch sehr spannend. Also das haben wir uns sozusagen mit ermöglicht, weil wir halt schon als die Spaßgeräte, die mit den Bessen galten. Und dann kamen die halt zu uns und hatten wir Gabba.
Ich hab's gerade mal nachgeschlagen hier. Klandestein Insurgent Rebel Clown Army nennen sie sich.
Sind wir das?
Nee, das sind die.
Sie hätten zumindest die Möglichkeit, sich als eigene Sektion der HI auszurufen.
Hätten sie auf jeden Fall.
Wenn sie denn wollen würden.
Ja, die haben doch damals auch Ärger bekommen. Denen hat die Polizei vorgeworfen, sie hätten Säure in ihren Wasserspritzpistolen. Was natürlich eine infame Lüge der Polizei war. Weil der im Prinzip auf jeden Fall nicht ist, mit Säure rumzuspritzen. Das ist auch interessant, dass die Polizei sich durchaus... Eine Aktionsform der Hedonistischen Internationale sind mobile Soundsysteme. Das heißt, ich baue mir dicke Boxen auf ein ziehbares Gefährt mit einer großen Autobatterie dran. Und kann dann mit diesen mobilen Soundsystemen irgendwo hingehen. Es gab hier auch Schnitzeljagden durch die Stadt mit acht Soundsystemen. Die Leute mussten irgendwelche Aufgaben. Küße einen Polizisten, geh zu McDonalds und mach irgendwie das und das. Damit kommen die nicht so richtig gut klar. Das ist nicht so eine Demo, die läuft entlang, da kann ich mit den Polizisten hin. Das sind dann immer 100 Leute, die hinter so einem Soundsystem hinterher und in verschiedene Straßen zu großen Hubschraubereinsätzen geführt haben. Das ist auch so ein Prinzip, mit diesen Soundsystemen was zu machen. Das hat man nicht vergessen. Das ist ein Kulturmerkmal.
Auch da wieder historische Vorbilder, das Umherschweifen.
Das ist noch mal ein anderer Prozess.
Das ist noch mal ein anderer Prozess, sich flexibel herumzuschweifen, nicht klar zuortenbar zu sein, nicht einen ganz klaren Ansprechpartner zu haben. Das kommt natürlich schnell in Konflikt mit Demonstrationsrechten. Das ist schon klar, aber immer noch eine innovative Podcast-Form.
Habt ihr eigentlich, ich meine, ist das jetzt so, macht ihr das jetzt eigentlich nur so für euch? Ist das sozusagen so euer Gefühl, dass ihr das einfach tun wollt und jetzt habt ihr das in diesen Rahmen hineingelegt, sag ich mal ganz zurückhaltend und ihr freut euch daran, dass andere das auch machen? Oder ist es schon auch ein bisschen Mission?
Mission, das ist ein christlicher Begriff.
Man könnte es auch militärisch begriffen.
Natürlich ist das eine Überzeugung. Das ist auf jeden Fall, es ist eine Mischung aus Überzeugung und Spaß. Natürlich ist es eine Überzeugung, dass das gut ist, dass das tatsächlich was verändert. Gleichzeitig aber auch ein Zugeständnis, jedenfalls so wie ich das sehe, dass man nicht absehen kann, was man damit verändert, dass man nicht gleich alles verändern muss. Ja klar, und sonst macht es natürlich auch einfach riesen Freude.
Was denkst du, was es denn verändern könnte? Oder vielleicht auch tut?
Mir geht es persönlich darum, dass Leute sehen, dass man was verändern kann, wenn man sich zusammentut mit anderen. Wenn auch nur durch diese ganzen Aktionen drei Personen diesen Glauben daran, dass Veränderung möglich ist, erhalten haben, war es ja schon ein Erfolg. Wenn Leute diesen Glauben verlieren, wir können eh nichts machen, dann spitzen sich autoritäre Prozesse in der Gesellschaft zu. Dann wird es irgendwie enger, dann werden Bürgerrechte noch schneller abgebaut. Ich glaube, es ist wichtig, dass Leute an diese Veränderung, an die Möglichkeit der Veränderung glauben. Das wäre schön, wenn das...
Du glaubst an die Veränderung?
Ja, auch wenn es ständig wieder enttäuscht wird. Klar, ich glaube, alles andere macht... Dann müsste ich aufhören, politisch zu sein, weil dann ist es ja nur noch frustrierend, wenn man nicht dran glauben kann, dass sich was ändern kann.
Also wenn man defensiv denkt, dann ist es einfach, dass man durch diese Aktionen sich Freiräumer erhält, wie gesagt. Also Bürgerrechte und dass man sozusagen durch das Beschreiten von Grenzen überhaupt darauf aufmerksam macht, dass es Grenzen gibt.
Zumindest die Verschlimmerung eindämmen.
Obwohl das ja nicht gerade sexy ist, so Abwehrkampf.
Ich sage ja, wenn man das defensiv sieht, ist es das und wenn man das natürlich progressiv sieht und sagt, wir wollen eigentlich mehr, dann kann man durchaus sagen, indem man Bilder prägt, indem man Selbstverständlichkeiten angreift in der Gesellschaft, dann kann das einen Teil dazu beitragen, einen kleinen Teil, dass bestehende Verhältnisse, das hört sich jetzt wieder sehr Marxistisch an, aber das sind bestehende Verhältnisse, die nicht okay sind und auf Dauer überwunden werden, weil durch diese Aktionen die Normalität reflektiert wird, die Leute werden zum Denken angeregt. Klar kann das was ändern, tut es auch, ist auch deswegen hochgefährlich, glaube ich. Freut mich auch.
Du hast ja vorhin schon erwähnt, eine der Sachen, die glaube ich auch so ein bisschen noch bekannter geworden sind als manche anderen Sachen. Ich bin ehrlich gesagt über den Bekanntheitsgrad eurer einzelnen Aktionen im Einzelnen gar nicht so im Klaren, weil mal kriegt man das so nebenbei mit, mal, ja vielleicht auch nicht, genau, mal erschlägt es einen. Du hast ja vorhin schon angesprochen, die Sache mit dem Gutenberg. Ich meine, das war ja auch so ein Fall, also jetzt wo du gerade gesagt hast, dass man manchmal auch glaubt, dass Dinge sich gar nicht ändern können. Das ist ja auch irgendwie so ein bisschen gewohnt, dass die Politiker oder sagen wir mal, vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter ausgefaltet so eine gewisse herrschende Klasse, einen Freiraum genießt, indem sie sich förmlich alles erlauben kann. Und gerade diese Doktor-Titel-Nummer, wo es ja jetzt nicht nur einen, sondern gleich eine ganze Reihe von Umstürzen gab, wo man so den Eindruck gewonnen hat, also ich habe zumindest den Eindruck gewonnen, das wäre jetzt vor ein paar Jahren so nicht gegangen. Das mag und hat auch mit dem Internet zu tun, ganz klar, gerade diese Gutenplug-Wiki-Dynamik. Man merkt, auf einmal gibt es die Werkzeuge, auf einmal gibt es diese virtuellen Gemeinden und das Zusammenkommen, und es ist ganz klar, dass das alles damit zu tun hat. Auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich dann auch, unabhängig davon, ein gesellschaftlicher Schritt gemacht worden und dann eben auch etwas demonstriert worden, nämlich dieses, hier Alter, du kommst mit der Nummer einfach nicht durch. Und dann eskalierte das ja in diesen Demonstrationen gegen ihn, mit hier Schuhe auf den Zaun und so weiter. Was wirklich schon mal hervorragende Bilder waren. Also auch dieser direkte Wutausbruch, der hat sich auch des humoristischen in gewisser Hinsicht bedient. Kann man auch groß in Anführungsstriche setzen, dieses Bild mit der Verachtung aus dem arabischen Raum jetzt auf einmal übertragen auf das europäische. Und dann gab es ja wenige Tage später dann auch tatsächlich den Rücktritt und dann eben so diese merkwürdige Gegenbewegung mit jetzt wollen wir ihn aber wieder haben.
500.000 auf Facebook angeblich.
Ich habe das auch erst nur mitverfolgt, fand das Gutenplug großartig. Und es war dann bei mir auch einfach eine Sache der persönlichen Empörung. Dieser Typ war genau das, was ich furchtbar finde. Da kenne ich viele Menschen in meinem Umfeld, die schreiben jahrelang unter Verlust ihrer Gesundheit an Doktorarbeiten. Und dann kommt dieser gelagte Typ da lang und glaubt wirklich, er kann damit durchkommen. Hat sich ja bewahrheitet an Vollbetrüge. Und dann, als er gegangen war, nachdem er noch auf die Mitleidstour gemacht hatte, und er zurückgeholt werden sollte durch das Volk, ich sag mal ganz bewusst hier Volk, und 500.000 Leute angeblich auf Facebook, die Like-Bottons betätigt hatten und diesen Foren beigetreten waren, da war es mir persönlich und ich glaube uns allen ein Anliegen, da doch nochmal nachzutreten. Und zwar einfach in der Hinsicht, dass dieser Mann hin und wieder zurückkommt. Und das geht eigentlich nur, wenn man dann nochmal ganz klar macht, wie absurd es ist, einen Betrüger, was er ja faktisch war und ist, da vielleicht noch irgendwie wegkommen zu lassen. Der ist ja jetzt schon in den Staaten, glaube ich, sitzt dort bei einer Unternehmensberatung und versucht, die Tour dann irgendwann wieder in die Politik einzusteigen. Und das sah ich schon von meinem inneren Auge, und ich dachte, das muss behoben werden.
Ich meine, das Lustige war, da gab es ja davor diese Demo mit den Schuhen am Verteidigungsministerium und so. Ich finde, da hat sehr viel medial eine Rolle gespielt, den Medien neue Bilder zu geben mit den Schuhen und der Demo und irgendwie Leuten. Das ist wichtig, um so ein Skandal auch anzufeuern. Da nochmal irgendwie so ein paar Scheite rauflegen, ein paar Bilder. Und ich fand es dann gut, ich hatte ein Schild irgendwie mit...
Wart ihr da eigentlich auch schon mit dabei?
Wobei man das vielleicht trennen sollte. Also, einfach Ehre wem Ehre gebührt. Das mit den Schuhen war jemand anders und das war großartig. Ich weiß nicht genau, aus welchem Kreis das kam. Ist auch eigentlich unwichtig. Aber genau so soll es ja eigentlich laufen. Da hat jemand eine wahnsinnig gute Idee. Nimmt die arabische Symbol der Verachtung, trägt das Vorsverteidigungsministerium und das ist ein großer, riesiger Spaßumzug gleichzeitig, der aber natürlich eine berechtigte Empörung ausdrückt.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich erzählen wollte. Das lustige war eben erst eine Woche davor, gegen ihn zu demonstrieren und dann das Schild zu haben. Irgendwie Junkernland in Bauernhand. Und die Woche darauf hatten wir dann ein Schild gemalt mit Bauernland in Junkernhand.
Das muss man vielleicht mal kurz zusammenfassen. Also es gab dann, es gab die Gegendemo, dann gab es den Rücktritt und dann gab es so diese medial gesteigerte, ja, aber es gibt ja jetzt auch Kräfte, die wollen ihn ja wieder haben, weil das kann ja nicht sein, so ein netter Typ war und alle schüttelten nur noch mit.
Es geht ja in die Richtung, wir wollen ja eigentlich unseren Kaiser wieder haben, das war ja auch ganz klar. Deswegen waren wir ja dann ja auch da, was waren wir denn da? Die Monarcho-Hedonistische Front. Darum geht es ja. Und Oberbefehlshaber, der kometenhaft aufgeschiegen ist tatsächlich. Und da konnte man ja eigentlich auch da nur noch zuspitzen und eigentlich das sagen, was die ganzen Fälle sind.
Aber wer hat denn diese Demos dann angeleiert?
Genau, ich glaube, das war die schöne Geschichte an diesem ganzen Ding ist, dass ein Jemand, ein Strohmann letztlich bei der Versammlungsbehörde, also jemand von der Monarcho-Hedonistischen Front, hat sich als CDU-Sympathisant ausgegeben bei der Versammlungsbehörde und sich auch dummgestellt und noch nie eine Demo angemeldet und alles, also so richtig gut gespielt auch. Und denen gesagt, ja, ich mach hier eine Demonstration für den Gutenberg und wie geht denn das alles und ich will Brandenburger Tor. Und dann hatte irgendwann die Versammlungsbehörde einen Tag später gerufen, ja, es gibt noch eine zweite Demo, die wollen vom Potsdamer Platz, das waren dann die echten Gutenberg-Fans, die wollen vom Potsdamer Platz zum Brandenburger Tor laufen. Und wollen sie das nicht zusammen machen? Und dann hatte unser Strohmann gesagt, nee, dann können die ja da ran. Und dann hatte sich dann tatsächlich die echte Demo, unsere Demo angeschlossen, was den Vorteil hat. Also die meinten dann auch, ja, der Brandenburger Tor ist ja doch besser und medienwirksamer. Und den Vorteil hat er, wenn man auf eine fremde Demo geht und dort Scheiße baut oder irgendwie mit eigenen Schildern, dann darf die Demo, hat so eine Art Hausrecht. Das heißt, der Versammlungsleiter darf der Polizei sagen, bitte die Leute raus, das sind irgendwelche Linken oder so. Was in dem Fall nicht mehr ging. Die Polizei kam immer zu unserem Versammlungsleiter, Herr XY und Herr XY, hier sind Linksradikale. Wollen sollen wir die rausschmeißen?
Alexander Müller hieß er. Wir hatten das auch so vereinbart. Alexander Müller hieß Alexander Müller, der nicht Alexander Müller hieß, das war auch das Schöne dabei. Denn die Medien stürzten sich natürlich auf ihn als Anmelder und fragten, wie ist denn ihr Name? Ja sagen sie das bitte nicht, schreibt gerade mal Doktorarbeit.
Das war dieses Interview. Ich fand diesen Prozess mit dieser Polizei eigentlich noch lustig, dass die die ganze Zeit hinkamen und sagen, sie verstehen das vielleicht nicht, das ist Ironie. Und haben immer versucht, die Leute aus der Demo zu drängen, die aber eigentlich halt auch. Also es war eine schöne Verwirrung. Aber erst am Schluss haben sie es, glaube ich, kapiert, dass er nicht auch schön verkleidet und sah auch ein bisschen so...
Adrett aus.
Adrett aus, hat auch genau diesen Stil, den man in diesem Video hören kann. Genau diesen Stil hat er gegenüber der Polizei auch durchgezogen. Und die sind auch...
Also dieses Video, das ist ein, das wollte ich auch nicht geplant haben. Ausgerechnet dieses Dialogs, wo dann, ich glaube, jemand vom RBB ihn dann interviewt. Und er dann sozusagen den Sermon ablässt, so im Sinne von, ja, wir wollen ja unseren guten Werk wieder haben und so weiter.
Also geplant nicht, aber natürlich, wie gesagt, diese Pseudonymität, ist mir deswegen so wichtig, weil die schönsten Sachen sind zu denen, die schönsten Aktionen sind die, zu denen sich niemand bekennt. Das kommt von Sonja Brunzels, der Verfasserin, von dem Handbuch der Mediengeräte.
Kommunikationsgeräte.
Kommunikationsgeräte, Entschuldigung. Und ja, das fand ich einen sehr treffenden Spruch. Das sind wirklich die schönsten Aktionen, zu denen darf man sich nicht bekennen. Da gibt es dann keinen, der wirklich ansprechbar ist. Oder du hast halt einfach einen falschen Namen im Netz bei so einem Video, was dann natürlich wahnsinnig gerne angeguckt wird. Und es geht nicht darum, dass die Person vielleicht selber nicht so betroffen ist, sondern alleine, dass du da noch mal einen falschen Namen hinstellst, bricht die Situation noch mal in wunderbarer Weile.
Ich fand das Tolle an dem Ding war, einerseits, du hast ja auch z.B. Interviews gegeben mit so Christenfanatisch. Ja, und er wird auferstehen und auf so auf die Tour irgendwie in die Kamera. Aber gut, wir hatten halt einfach viele Schilder gemalt. Wir hatten einfach irgendwie 50 Schilder gemalt mit Militär-Podgetz sofort oder irgendwie.
Du hast die Haare schön.
Das war irgendjemand anders, der kam.
Aber das war großartig. Dann fließt sowas zusammen, da kommen auch noch echte Anhänger und das fließt dann zusammen und du hast wahnsinnig viele Schilder.
Echte Anhänger, die dann Militär-Podgetz heißen.
Es gab ja auch nicht nur die eine Demo, es gab mindestens noch eine in Hamburg.
Ja, das war auch der Hedonistische Internationale.
Also im Prinzip waren nahezu alle Demos pro Gutenberg von der Hedonistischen Internationale geläuscht.
Und anderen Gruppen, da gab es noch andere Gruppen, da gab es noch Kommunisten für Gutenberg, die sagen, kopieren ist der wahre Kommunismus. Die hatten da auch, die hatten in Köln sind die auch aufgelaufen. In München hat sich jemand als Monarchist reingeschlichen als Mikrofon und hat Gutenberg zum König von Bayern aus gerufen.
Also interessant, das heißt, da haben eigentlich wirklich mehrere Leute irgendwie dieselbe Idee gehabt. Und dann auch exekutiert.
Genau.
Und das war ja dann eigentlich die, also für mich, in meiner Wahrnehmung war das, also erst als ich das gehört hatte pro Gutenberg, da wollte ich nur noch Kopf schütteln, so. Dann habe ich irgendwie dieses Medienergebnis dann auch gesehen. Auch in Hamburg ging das ja schon so los. Und ich dachte mir so, also der Rücktritt war einfach nichts dagegen. Also das hat ihn nun wirklich vollständig vernichtet, weil die Medien ja auch sich selbst da eigentlich komplett in die eigene Falle gegangen sind. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben die das auch genossen irgendwo. Ab bestimmten Punkten müssen sie es ja auch verstanden haben.
Da hatten viele lachende Journalisten dort. Also Journalisten sind bei solchen Sachen ganz oft deine Freunde, weil die ja nah dran sind und die freuen sich auch, so was zu sehen. Es ist klar, das spricht denen ein Stück weit auch aus dem Herzen. Wenn die da eine ganz normale Pro-Gutenberg-Demo gesehen hätten, dann wird denen ja auch oft schlecht. Das sind ja auch arbeitende Menschen.
Ja, ich glaube, das hat dem Gutenberg schon noch mal... Das Einzige, wo seine Demo geklappt hat, war in seinem Heimatdorf.
Und die war noch absurder.
Die war tatsächlich sehr... Mit diesem Kuchen, der da aufgeschnitten wurde, mit dem Bild von ihm drauf.
Das ging echt gar nicht mehr.
Aber es geht schon darum, so Bilder zu... Und dann hat diese Gutenberg-Aktion sogar dazu geführt, dass die Junge Union Wuletal... Also ich hatte so einen Junge Union Wuletal. Wir sind die Guten mit Doppel-T. Und dann unten Junge Union Wuletal. Und stand mit diesem Transparent, worauf ich begrüßt wurde von irgendwelchen jungen Unionlerinnen. Die gibt's wirklich. Das sind die, die dieses Junge Union, dieses furchtbare Lied ins Netz gestellt hatten. Und die haben dann später dementiert, dass sie niemals auf dieser Demo gewesen sind. Das ist immer schön auch, weil die auf jedem Bild dann drauf waren, auf den Pressebildern und die falsche Junge Union.
Wenn du dann eben eben noch einen Dementi hast, das ist einfach schön. Noch mal ein persönlicher Guddi.
Jetzt komme ich nochmal zurück zu dem Punkt, der mich auf Guttenberg gebracht hat. Das war eine Änderung, oder? Vielleicht überhöre ich das jetzt zu sehr. Meine Wahrnehmung war, dass mit dieser Pro-Guttenberg-Demo eine extrem nachhaltige Demontage war, die tatsächlich diese Änderung, von der du vorhin gesprochen hast, die so wünschenswert wäre, auch mindestens mit eingeleitet hat oder begleitet hat.
Ich glaube, dass Leute lächerlich machen, ist ein sehr mächtiges Instrument. Ob das jetzt Digitarski ist oder Guttenberg, ist irgendjemand, irgendetwas lächerlich zu machen, das tut weh. Und es wird Guttenberg, also, man darf es nicht überhöhen, aber es wird auf jeden Fall ihm das Schwere machen, zurückzukommen. So ein Stückchen. Genau wie die Demo die Woche davor, 0,7 Prozent am Rücktritt Anteil hatte oder 1,5 Prozent. Also, keine Ahnung, man kann das ja nicht messen. Aber ich glaube, das wird schon irgendeinen Anteil haben.
Ich denke, dass diese Demos vorher zumindest zu der Erkenntnis, die Erkenntnis befördert haben, dass, wenn sie da jetzt nicht den Sack zumachen, dass es noch viel schlimmer wird. Dass das nicht enden würde.
Aber es wird sich halt noch zeigen, ob der nicht doch zurückkommt. Ich ahne, der wird es probieren.
Ja, ich ahne aber auch. Aber ich glaube, das wird dann echt ein Field-Day. Keinen Spaß haben.
Darum geht es auch nicht.
Digitask, was es jetzt gerade erwähnt, das ist jetzt hier sozusagen das top aktuelle Ding. Wir befinden uns jetzt gerade in der Zeit, wo der Chaos Computer Club einen Code des sogenannten Staats- oder Bundestrojaners veröffentlicht hat, kommentiert hat und genau aufgezeigt hat, was er kann, woraufhin dann die Behörden etwas durcheinander waren und sich über Tage in einem Dementi-Spaghetti verfangen haben und am Ende alle zugeben mussten, was sie denn damit jetzt alles schon schönes getan haben. Die Firma Digitask ist der mutmaßliche Hersteller dieses Codes und ihr habt dann angefangen, den im Internet, ich glaube auf Twitter zu vertreten.
Da kam eine Mail, also von Leuten, wir sind das. Die haben sich in einer Sektion Innovation durch Kompetenz, Büro für spezielle Kommunikationslösungen, das ist eigentlich eins zu eins übernommen von der Firma. Die hatten einfach getwittert in deren Namen. Und die Firma Digitask hatte das dann sehr ernst genommen.
Ja.
Und hat dann auch die Webseite, wie wir sie haben, wir sind nicht im Social-Netz aktiv, hat dann auf der Webseite stehen.
Also es war wieder irgendeine Sektion sozusagen.
Und die haben einfach getwittert im Namen von Digitask und haben aber so getan, dass sie hier, unsere Twitter-Dialog-Hotline ist jetzt von 8 bis 24 Uhr geöffnet. Stellen sie ihre Fragen. Woraufhin auch lauter Fragen kamen, die dann in dem gleichen Stil von Digitask beantwortet wurden. Also sie haben gegen ihre... Stimmt, das ist ja... Ja, dazu war auf jeden Fall... Hat es dazu geführt, dass sie dann Strafanzeige angedroht hatten wohl und...
Wem gegenüber?
Ja, die werden jetzt eine Strafanzeige gestellt, hieß es, haben Journalisten berichtet. Und werden jetzt versuchen, bei Twitter die Daten rauszukriegen, wer... Wer da getwittert hat. Und ansonsten hatten sie dann das Bekennerschreiben, Bekennerschreiben klingt immer gleich so nach Anschlage, also das Erklärungsschreiben oder was das war, von dieser Sektion. Dagegen hatten sie dann noch eine Abmahnung angedroht. Worauf rausgekommen ist, das hat mir dann irgendjemand vom CCC erzählt, der Anwalt hatte geschrieben, ja, wir verkaufen gar nicht nach Saudi-Arabien und sonst wie, wir verkaufen nur nach Österreich, Deutschland, Schweiz und Niederlande, woraufhin österreichische Regierung sagen musste, oh, ja, wir haben damit auch zu tun. Also, das ist ein schöner Nebeneffekt von so einem kleinen Fake-Twitter-Account mit 200 Followern.
Gut, wenn man verklagt wird, also man kann da eigentlich immer eine Zurat, also wenn man eine Anzeige bekommt und einen Anwalt schreiben, dann ist ja die halbe Miete öffentlichkeitswirksam schon wieder im Sack.
Das war jetzt aber nicht die erste Geschichte, die so auf Twitter gelaufen ist, ne? Da gab es noch dieses Atomforum.
Atomforum gab es, ja, das war zur Fukushima-Katastrophe, da hatte sich in der Sektion gleich mehrere Accounts, die hatten auch Tabco und Atomforum und haben dann sehr zynische Tweets rausgehauen, das bisschen Strahlung und macht man nicht so. Und da hat das Atomforum dann auch angedroht, ne Abmahnung, und das aber auch nicht gemacht, die haben das abschalten lassen, den Account. Weil man bei Twitter mittlerweile das kennzeichnen muss, wenn man Satire macht, was natürlich bei einem Fake-Account irgendwie ziemlich langweilig ist, wenn ich dazuschreibe Satire. Dann muss ich keinen Fake-Account machen.
Das ist generell ein bisschen schwierig. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie sich das entwickelt. Weil Satire muss eigentlich möglich sein. Natürlich ist Satire keine Satire, wenn man Satire draufschreibt. Und das ist immer ein bisschen...
Ein Fake muss halt auch gut sein. Ich glaube, das ist aber auch so ein Ding bei diesen Twitter-Fakes immer so, da ist ganz viele Leute sich irgendwas sichern und dann das total verkacken ab dem ersten Tweet, irgendwie gleich so das enttarnt haben. Und wenn du das so richtig machst, du dich so reinversetzt in das Firma DigiTask und irgendwelche ZDF-Journalisten fangen an zu recherchieren, ist das echt? Und hat der das dann so... Das muss man irgendwie hinkriegen, weil viele Leute das mit diesen Fakes nicht hinkriegen. Und faken ist ja schon irgendwie auch...
Ist eine Kunst.
Und ein Spaß.
Es gab ja auch eine Sache, die so ein bisschen mehr Wind gemacht hat. Das war eine Produktion von Polylux, die bei welchem Sender eigentlich mittlerweile untergekommen sind.
Gar nicht mehr, die wurden mittlerweile abgesägt.
Ja, aber damals war das ARD, oder?
Das war ARD, Abend-Nachtprogramm.
Und was... Ich hab's nicht so ganz mitbekommen. Also, die haben jemanden gesucht, öffentlich, oder was?
Also, im Vorfeld muss man sagen, Polylux war ja ein Fan, sozusagen, von uns. Die mussten ja auch immer wieder neue Geschichten produzieren, die hip und trendy waren. Das Label Hedonismus war sehr hip und trendy geworden. Und die fragten über verschiedene Kanäle immer wieder an, in großer Regelmäßigkeit, ob sie nicht noch eine Geschichte machen könnten. Wir hatten, ja, jedenfalls ich damals, das Gefühl, die wollen über uns, wir sind so ein bisschen die Story-Maschine. Also wir sollen die hippen urbanen Geschichten liefern.
Und haben aber dann in ihrem typischen Stil, das ist auch immer so über Form, Polylux war so ein Magazin, die haben die Geschichte vorher im Kasten. Und dann wird die gemacht so. Und dann wird dein Zitat so geschnitten, das sind ihre vorherige Geschichte, die sie sich zusammen, anhand ihrer Protagonisten bauen die sich so eine Geschichte. Und die haben dann in einem Forum, einem tatsächlichen Forum, nach Leuten gesucht, die den ganzen Tag Speed nehmen.
In so einem Web-Forum, oder was?
Ja, das wurde später herausgefunden, dass das eine Methode ist, die haben in allen möglichen Forum gesucht. Wir suchen Leute, die auf andere stehen, die nur einen Arm haben. Wir suchen Leute mit Uni-Angst. Hallo, hier ist die Redaktion Polylux. Das ist eine sehr billige oder schlechte Recherchermethode, weil der Haken hängt im Forum und ich hänge mich dran und kann denen irgendwas vom Pferd erzählen. Genau das wurde dann gemacht. Dann hieß Tim, oder? Der falsche Köder hieß Tim. Er war ein übergewichtiger Mensch, der mit 160 Kilo und jetzt versucht auf Speed, seine Speed-Diät, und seit sechs Wochen nur Äpfel und Speed. Und Polylux hat diese Geschichte noch untermauert mit so einem Wissenschaftler. Ja, der Gesellschaft geht hin zum Speed und dann immer ihn mit seiner gefälschten Geschichte, mit dieser Speed-Diät.
Was ja eigentlich natürlich hängt, hängt es sich damals an, die Entschleunigungsdiskussion dran. Wir entschleunigen, wir haben dieses Wort vor kurzem wieder gehört. Die ganze Gesellschaft überbeschleunigt sich und so. Also eigentlich löblich, man will gesellschaftskritisch sein, aber es rutscht halt in diesen Pseudokontext. Das gesellschaftskritische wird hip, aber auf so eine Art. Und dass es verkürzt erscheint. Also mir lief das zuwider, ein Stück weit, diese Art der Berichterstattung. Aber erzähl noch was dazu, Karl.
Ja, das wurde dann gesendet. Und wir hatten davor auch, also das hieß diese Sektion, Kommando Tito von Hardenberg. Also die Moderatorin war Tita von Hardenberg. Und das Kommando Tito von Hardenberg hat halt im Moment der Sendung dann ein Bekenner-Video, also so richtig so Islamisten-Style, so richtig mit so Hassmasken, aber halt ein Computer noch dabei statt der Kalaschnikow. Und halt Pressemitteilung raus. Und das ist richtig hochgekocht und am Schluss...
Warte mal, was wurde denn in diesem Video dann gesagt von dem Menschen?
Er hat gesagt, ja, und ich... Also letztlich war das nur, die sind halt einem falschen Protagonisten aufgesessen. Und der hat erzählt, dass er...
Er hat dann einfach nur von Speed und von Äpfeln lebt.
Speed und Äpfel, und er müsste abnehmen. Und der Leistungsdruck der Gesellschaft, hat denen halt einfach nur Dreck erzählt.
Und weil sie geliefert, was sie hören wollen.
Genau. Und das wurde dann, weil das bei öffentlich-rechtlichen, wenn es schlechte Recherche...
Das wurde auch ausgestrahlt.
Es wurde ausgestrahlt. Und in dem Moment ist irgendwie die Pressemitteilung an 400 Redaktionen gegangen. Was dazu geführt hat, dass...
Zu dem Zeitpunkt der Ausstrahlung. Genau in der Minute, der Tag, oder...
Exakt in dem Moment.
Wobei mir die Volontärin, die das gemacht hat, bis heute noch ein bisschen Leid tut. Das war natürlich nicht gegen sie gerichtet eigentlich.
Nee, das nicht. Aber das war... Die Recherche war so dermaßen schlecht von diesen Magazinen. Was hat ihnen wahrscheinlich auch das Genick gekostet. Der Pressesprecher des RPB hat das gesagt. Nein, nein, nein, es hat nichts damit zu tun. Eine dreifache Verneinung kann man auch anders deuten.
Okay, es dauerte zumindest nicht so lange, bis Polylux dann nicht mehr sendet.
Ja, ein halbes Jahr später war das dann vorbei. Das war sicher nicht beabsichtigt. Es ging eigentlich, glaube ich, den Leuten eher darum, so ein bisschen den eins auszuwischen und auch vorzuführen, wie schlechte Recherche zu hintertreiben ist. Also das funktioniert ja auch immer wieder.
Das Format, vielleicht war das... Ich kann jetzt nur mutmaßen, das Format war vielleicht tatsächlich auch schon am Ende, weil dieses ständige Produzieren von hippen, urbanen Geschichten, die sozusagen in der Illegalität sich halbwegs bewegen, im Halbschatten der Großstadt, das war vielleicht einfach ein Stück weit ausgereizt. Da kann man nicht ständig nachproduzieren.
Wobei ich glaube, so RTL und ähnliche Sender...
Die reden nicht von den Abgründen.
Ich glaube, denen kann man auch... Aber da ist das Problem, da wirst du diese Überzeichnung nicht hinbekommen. Also wenn ich bei RTL einen falschen Protagonisten hinbringe, in irgendeiner Show, wird nachher nicht jemand sagen, oh, das ist aber ein Skandal, weil das erwarte ich ja von denen, dass da falsche Protagonisten mir Dreck erzählen. Wobei eben das Öffentlich-Rechtliche eben diesen Nimbus der Objektivität hat. Und da funktioniert es eben nicht. Und da wird das dann skandalisiert.
Ja, aber ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob euch das bekannt ist. Es gibt ja hier so... Es gibt viele Beispiele. Mir fällt jetzt eins ein hier. Was weiß ich hier, diese Super-Nanny. Weiß schon wieder nicht, in welchem Kanal. Irgendwas mit RTL 1, 2, 3. Wo auch jetzt durch interessante Dokumentationen nachgewiesen wurde, so wirklich mal, wie die Methoden sind, wie die ihre Geschichten finden. Wobei es ja dann auch immer noch Leute trifft, die dann einfach unter dieser Berichterstattung auch noch doppelt zu leiden haben. Also finanziell rufschädigend und psychisch vernichtend geradezu. Das ist natürlich dann auch ein Aufschlagsort für spaßgetriebenen Anarchismus, der vielleicht eben die Möglichkeit hat, auch solchen Produktionsmethoden, vielleicht nicht ein Ende zu setzen, aber doch zumindest mal einen Warnbanner auf die Stirn zu schreiben.
Also das Problem bei Leuten, die eigentlich grenzenlos zynisch sind, indem sie ständig sowas produzieren, denen an den Kahn zu fahren durch Überspitzung, durch Überaffirmationen, ist total schwer. Man würde eigentlich ihnen zuarbeiten. Die freuen sich doch darüber, wenn ihre Sendung wieder erwähnt wird, weil, hey, da wurde eine Mutter aufgenommen. Das war ja das Letzte, was da bei Super Nanny irgendwie kam. Die Mutter, die vor laufender Kamera ihre Tochter schlägt. Die freuen sich natürlich auch jetzt, wenn sie jetzt genannt werden. Also was macht man da? Nicht mal ignorieren? Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Es ist auf jeden Fall schwierig, sie zu erspitzen. Ich meine, es gab auch Sachen, es gab irgendwelche, es war mal irgendein Sender, ich glaube ProSieben, mit irgendeiner komischen Reportagesendung. Die wollten unbedingt über diese nackten Wohnungsbesichtigungs-Rallyes. Die Zeit lang sind Leute einfach, sind zu Wohnungsbesichtigungen gegangen, von Luxuswohnungen, die zu teuer sind. Und sie haben sich nackt ausgezogen und sind da rumgetanzt. Und haben das dann auch veröffentlicht und warum, und welche Wohnung und wie teuer. Und da wollte unbedingt ProSieben ran. Und niemand hatte Lust, mit ProSieben das zu machen, wenn es irgendwie nettere Journalisten gibt. Und daraufhin haben die einfach sich das selber zusammengeschnitten und haben gesagt, ja, wir haben hier erhalten diesen Brief und haben einfach was erfunden, fand ich. Also deswegen ist es schwer, die zu überzeichnen. Also wenn die selber schon solche Methoden anwenden.
Naja, aber in dem Moment, wo man halt das dokumentiert, ja, das ist ja jetzt das Element gewesen, bei diesem Apfel-Speed-Diät hätte es diese Pressemitteilung und diese Gegenöffentlichkeitsaktivität an der Stelle nicht gegeben, wäre ja Polylux da mit der Geschichte genauso durchgekommen wie alle anderen auch. Das ist das, was ich meine. Dass man auf einmal eine Gegenöffentlichkeit erzeugt, mit der sie wahrscheinlich so nicht rechnen. Weil diese Familien, die dort halt ausgenutzt werden, die haben ja allein schon psychisch, physisch, finanziell von ihren Verbindungen her keine Möglichkeit, diese Öffentlichkeit zu erzeugen. Wenn man das vorher vorbereitet, stellt man interessante Fälle, sodass es eben auch gefährlicher wird, so einen Scheiß zu produzieren.
Das haben wir schon mal darüber nachgedacht. So eine Show, die auf den größtmöglichen, meine Mutter hat Krebs, der Vater hat die Andere erschossen, Kinder, das größtmögliche Schicksalsschlag. Und denen mal sowas anzuhängen. Und dann zu sagen, hey, auf was geht ihr überhaupt?
Also Vorschläge sind immer willkommen.
Neue Sektionen können sich jederzeit gründen. Ihr bringt mich jetzt hier schon in so einen Kreativitätsschub. Ja, also diese Nackten gab es dann sozusagen nur bei O7. Gab es diese Nackten eigentlich wirklich oder ist das nur so ein Mythos?
Ne, die Nackten gab es tatsächlich. Also die gab es wirklich. Das mit Mythos ist... Das geht auch. Also das ist eine schöne Aktion auch. Diese Kaufhaus-Mediamarkt-Geschichte fand ich. Da gab es irgendwie mal so eine Mediamarkteröffnung am Alexanderplatz.
Ja, dieses große, riesige Teil.
Genau. Und wir hatten dann nachts irgendwie um 12. Billiger. 5.000 Leute stehen davor. Und da sind halt die Sektionen umher schweifender Hedonistinnen, sind da hingegangen mit 200 Leuten mit Musik und eben 1, 2, 3, gebt die iPods frei und nur so eine, jetzt wir sind hier.
Und das Mitfeiern im Konsum raus.
Zum Mitfeiern, aber zum Plündern auch. Also fast eine Mischung, was dazu geführt hat, dass die Polizei dann auf den Kasten und das Ganze abgebrochen wurde und so, weil so ein Chaos gemacht wurde. Zwei Jahre später hat Saturn gleiche Werbeschienen. Hey, der Medienmarkt hat auch damals große Werbung und so. Wollte Saturn das Gleiche machen auch irgendwie, Dienstag Nacht, gleiche Nummer. Und da gab es nur eine Ankündigung, dass man, wir kommen nicht mit 400 Leuten und blockieren das. Einfach eine Pressemitteilung rausgehauen, die dann aufgebauscht wurde von RBB unter anderem. Woraufhin die da riesen Aufgebote und Polizei, die man sich durch die Webcams sich anschauen, am Alexanderplatz, was die da auffahren. Und es hat wirklich niemand gekommen.
Das war die Abendschau. Wir werden sicherlich nicht mit 100 aktiviert. Das funktioniert, wenn die Arbeit vorher schon getan ist, kann man dann immer ankündigen und kommen. Oder auch nicht kommen.
Verstehe.
Man muss also ein bisschen spielen. Mit der Situation.
Nichts ist schöner, als einen von riesigen Polizeischahen überwachter Konsumtempel. Einfach ein schönes Bild. Man muss nichts mehr dazu sagen.
Es geht um das Spielen und das Berechten. Eine andere Aktion war, da haben Leute aufgerufen, da wurde diese O2-Arena, eine riesige Mehrzweckhalle, eröffnet. Es gab einen Aufruf, ein Einladungs-Flyer kommt, alle schön angezogen, in Anzügen. Das hat dann dazu geführt, dass die Polizei nicht ihr Feindbild war, der schwarze Kapuzen-Pulli-Mensch, sondern alle, die in Anzügen waren. Was ziemlich viele waren, weil die ganzen Promis und VIPs und Anzugträger als Feindbild gehabt haben. Und damit zu spielen und das zu drehen, ist so, denke ich, das macht...
Trauen sie niemanden mit Krawatte.
Also einfach so dieses normale... Die Linken, die sehen so aus. Die kommen dann... Du hast hier eine Werbekarte.
Ich habe die Werbekarte nachher mal vom Kongress reden, den wir machen. Das ist tatsächlich noch ein Anliegen. Den gibt es ja auch schon seit zwei Jahren, den Weltkongress der Hedonistischen Internationale.
Ah ja, der war doch erst.
Im Sommer halt, am Anfang.
Ja, ich hörte davon, aber ich hatte leider keine Gelegenheit, daran teilzunehmen. Na, erzähl doch mal.
Was gibt es zum Kongress zu sagen? Ja, also seit zwei Jahren machen wir den Weltkongress der Hedonistischen Internationale. Der ist ein Treffen, so wie wir selber sind, weitgehend frei und ungebunden. Man kommt hin und folgt dann dort tatsächlich Vorträgen. Gleichzeitig ist es natürlich auch ein Event zum Feiern, denn wir sind natürlich Hedonisten. Das gehört mit dazu. Und wir waren bis jetzt zweimal in der Altmark, das heißt Richtung Wendland da unten, und waren in alten Kaserngeländen. Und ich muss sagen, es war immer am Anfang des Sommers so um Pfingsten rum. Dieses Jahr war es sogar am Pfingsten ein schönes und freies Fest, und wir werden dich jetzt festnageln. Du bist natürlich auch herzlich eingeladen. Beim nächsten Mal musst du teilnehmen und einen Vortrag halten. Dann haben wir schon wieder einen Referenten mehr im letzten Jahr.
Hattet ihr einen Mangel an Referenten?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Du solltest dir einen Frauennamen geben, das finden wir dieses Jahr vielleicht ganz schön. Aber in diesem Jahr hatten wir zum Beispiel einen Professor da, der sich mit dem Hedonismus beschäftigt hat und selber ein Buch ausgegeben hat. Das fand ich ganz interessant. Der Verlag hat ihm gesagt, nenn das das Hedonistische Manifest. Da er dann das Hedonistische Manifest herausgebracht hat, als Philosophie-Professor, haben wir ihn eingeladen. Das war auch sehr spannend. Der kam mit einem Tuitanzug, das verwirrt, dass er auf einmal mitten in der Hippie-Kommune stand. Er hat sich am Schluss auch sehr gefreut, als Punks jubelnd aufstanden und ihm zujubelten.
Die Subversion ist wichtig, meinte er in seinem Vortrag. Subversion ist einer der wichtigsten Tugenden, die wir uns beibehalten.
Das ist ein großes Experiment. Das ist immer wieder prozesshaft. Das funktioniert aber im Augenblick ganz gut. Diese Mischung aus Vorträgen und Workshops, die man auch direkt vor Ort anbieten kann, und dem Feiern, das funktioniert erstaunlich gut. Ich will gar nicht zu viel Werbung dafür machen, weil es bisher so schön war.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, wie viele haben denn teilgenommen? 300 Leute waren ungefähr da.
Gerade Leute, 100 Stunden pro Gramm. Das Ganze ist sehr frei und mitmachen. Das basiert auch echt darauf, dass alle Leute mitorganisieren und mitmachen. Da kamen dann wirklich auch die Sektionen zusammen. Also viele. Und auf einmal waren Leute aus anderen Ländern, nach Schweden und Korsien.
Das war dann wirklich auch international.
Natürlich sicher mehr Deutsche.
Na gut, man war nicht nur unter sich. Wir haben jetzt viel über Aktionen, die in Deutschland gelaufen sind, geredet. Gibt es denn auch internationale Ereignisse, die jetzt so gut passen?
Zu was?
Zu dem, was ihr euch so darunter vorstellt. Also wo ihr jetzt auch sagt, okay, das ist jetzt aber auch wirklich genau, was in unserem Sinne war. Oder gibt es da eine andere Vorstellung davon, was die Hedonistische Internationale sein kann, leisten sollte?
Die Sektion Amerika, die so schnell wegräumt wurde, dazu kann man was sagen. Wo waren die?
In Minnesota. Die haben irgendwie gegen, auch ging es Sozialkürzungen in der Stadt, und haben eine Straßenparty, eine unangemeldete gemacht. Und das ging nicht so gut wie in Berlin. Sondern hat dazu geführt, dass Ruckzuck irgendwie die Anlage beschlagnahmt und die Leute erst mal abgeknastet wurden.
Das ist halt der Unterschied zwischen, das muss man auch mal hervorheben, zwischen dem, wo wir uns bewegen, zwischen unserem politischen Raum und dem.
Ich glaube, das ist sogar ein Unterschied. Das haben die Leute aus Greifswald erzählt, die Sektion, die meinen auch so, in Berlin ist es relativ schwierig, Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen. In Greifswald machst du irgendeine Aktion, und das ist dann gleich irgendwie in der Zeitung. Die meinen aber auch, es ist halt auch viel schwieriger, Leute zu finden, wenn du in Greifswald bist.
Aber die sind sehr hartnäckig. In Greifswald gibt es eine Sektion, die sind hochaktiv und hartnäckig und machen immer wieder sehr schöne Sachen zwischendurch von der Party am Strand in der Nähe eines Atomkraftwerks oder was heißt das? Ich bin mir gar nicht genau sicher. Bis hin zu den antifaschistischen Demonstrationen. Die feiern auch wahnsinnig viel. Ich habe sie mal letztens getroffen auf einem Theaterfest da hinten auf dem Kulturkosmos-Gelände. Dann meinten sie dort auch und hatten groß ein hedonistisches Plakat in der Wand. Ich wusste schon gar nicht. Ich dachte, mein Gott, jetzt hat es jemand übernommen. Jetzt sind wir endgültig im Mainstream angekommen. Jetzt müssen wir den Namen ändern. Dann meinten sie aber, sie haben immer den Witz, diesmal machen wir keine Technoparty. Das steht natürlich auch viel für den Kern, jedenfalls bei uns in Berlin und dort. Viel geht halt auch über das Feiern und über den Freiraum schaffen innerhalb eines Festes. Und den Leben für eine Zeit.
Also man darf auch schon Spaß haben in der Hedonistischen Internationale. Ja, total Spaß. Macht ihr auch hier die letzte Aktion auf der Wahlparty der FDP? Es war auch eher so Zufall, dass das in die Kameras eingefangen wurde, oder?
Nein, das war nicht Zufall. Das war ziemlich exakt geplant.
Es war absehbar, dass die FDP nicht ganz so vorteilhaft abschneiden würde bei der Abgeordnetenhauswahl in Berlin. Ich glaube, 1,8% waren es dann am Ende nur. Und was passiert?
Die Idee war, es gibt ja diesen 18 Uhr-Moment bei Wahlen. Und jetzt schalten wir in die SPD-Zentrale. Wie war die Stimmung, als das Ergebnis kam?
Und dann zack, auf dem Bima steht, wie viel Prozent haben wir denn wirklich gehabt?
Genau, und dann jubeln die oder es scharf machen. Und den Moment wollten wir eigentlich hacken. Das war so die Idee, da hinzugehen, sich einzuschleichen, Bier auf Kosten der FDP zu trinken für umsonst. Und dann aber grenzenlos zu jubeln bei den 1,8%. Und dann auch falsche Interviews geben. Also wir hatten auch Leute dabei, die dann gleich sofort in die Mikrofon, ja, das ist ein großartiger Tag für die FDP. Die FDP ist wieder da und irgend so einen Scheiß erzählt.
Ja, dieses Ergebnis gibt uns recht. Das gibt uns recht.
Und auf dieser Welle der Bundespolitik haben wir es erreicht. Und diesen Moment da einfach hinzugehen und zu jubeln zwischen diesen FDP-Lern, die einen komisch anschauen, die sich schon gewundert haben, ist das so viel los hier? Und ich habe vor so fünf vor sechs irgend so einen Typen belauscht. So viel los und wo kommen die ganzen jungen Leute her? Aber es ist schön, dass wir hier, obwohl das Ergebnis so schlecht werden wird.
Wie viele Leute waren da so vor Ort?
Es waren interessanterweise drei unterschiedliche Kommunikations-Gerillaleutgruppen da.
Also zwei waren tatsächlich die Gerillaleut und das andere war halt eine Partei, die Partei.
Was für Kommunikationsformen wählt ihr euch denn dann sozusagen für diese Aktion? Ich meine, auf der einen Seite musste das geheim bleiben. Geht das dann per E-Mail oder was?
Ja, es gibt einfach viele Sachen, die kann man halt nicht offen kommunizieren, weil wenn ich es auf einer Webseite schreibe, wir besetzen heute einen Fernsehturm, dann geht es halt nicht.
Also es gibt so Schneeballverteiler in irgendeiner Form.
Es gibt Schneeballverteiler. Man ruft sich im Zweifelsfall auch an bei so was. Bei der FDP-Aktion, obwohl die sehr schön war, hatte ich fast schon ein bisschen Skrupel, weil ich wusste, das würde sie furchtbar versägen. Auf der anderen Seite hatten sie es auch einfach verdient, weil sie FDP sind. Aber mir war das schon zu viel nachtreten. Auf der anderen Seite war es am Schluss doch gut und ganz viele Leute haben sich halt mitgefreut.
Am schönsten fand ich eigentlich diesen medialen Effekt. Das war vielleicht eine ZDF, da sagt dieser Typ noch, da gab es schon eine schöne Bild-Textschere, da sagt der ZDF-Reporter, ja, betretende Gesichter schweigen und sonst wie. Und hinten dran siehst du die Bilder, wo irgendwie Konfetti fliegt und so.
Ja, und gejubelt wird. Tolle Aufnahme. Er meinte wahrscheinlich das Abgeordnetenhaus, weil da stand er. Aber hinten dran wurde aus der Parteizentrale berichtet, die in der Mitte liegt. Und da wurde dann halt Konfetti geworfen, gejubelt. Das war einfach schön.
Aber die Aktion wurde in Teilen auch der Partei von Sonneborn zugeschrieben.
Das haben die eingeweiht oder denen Bescheid gesagt und gesagt, kommt doch auch. Aber eigentlich war die Idee von dem Ding, das unkommentiert stehen zu lassen. Dann gab es noch eine dritte Gruppe, die da auch kam. Die waren auch mit fünf Leuten da, hatten das Gleiche vor. Und wir wollten das eigentlich unkommentiert stehen lassen. Das heißt jubeln, dann möglichst viele Interviews geben, irgendwelche Fernsehkameras, irgendeinen Dreck erzählen, warum das gut ist und dann verschwinden. Das wäre viel schöner gewesen, als wenn die Partei ihre Logos in die Kamera hält und das Ganze sofort enttarnt ist.
Das haben sie dann getan oder was?
Ja, die haben halt sofort die Partei und dann ist Sonneborn nach vorne. Das war eigentlich total schade, weil man hätte das Ganze auflaufen lassen können und dann hätten die Leute gefragt, was ist das los? Da kann man sich dann drei Tage später zu bekennen.
Da sieht man, dass auch Spaßparteien Parteien bleiben, egal ob FDP oder Partei.
Wie steht ihr denn zu solchen Projekten? Ich meine, da gibt es ja auch nicht wenige. Die Partei ist sicherlich am bekanntesten von der Titanic-Gro. Aber es gibt ja hier auch in Berlin schon seit Ewigkeiten die APPD, Arbeit ist Scheiße. Wozu steht das nochmal? Anarchistische Pogopartei Deutschlands. Ich meine, das ist ja auch ein Versuch, dem Ernst des Politischen irgendwie mit so einem Spaß zu begegnen. Die Frage ist nur, was ist die Intention dieses Spaßes? Ist es sozusagen das plakative Darstellen, das ist mir egal? Oder wie seht ihr das?
Also die Urmutter, die fand ich immer ganz toll. Das war die KPDRZ, die Kreuzberger Patrioten, ein realistisches Zentrum oder sowas.
Ja genau, realistisches.
Mit Rauchverbot in Einbahnstraßen. Die hatten ja schon Anfang der 90er, noch in den 80ern solche einfach schönen Ideen. Das sind ja eigentlich sozusagen die Urmutter tatsächlich, diese Spaßparteien, würde ich mal sagen. Jedenfalls soweit ich mich erinnern kann.
Wie gab es Chancen, 2000 noch von Klingensieg?
Sie bezeichnet sich als die einzige demokratische Massenpartei der extremen Mitte.
Und die hatten damals halt schon recht.
Die waren super. Das ist eine ähnliche Idee, damit herumzuspielen. Die APBD, die kann ich nicht mehr ernst nehmen, die hatten einen richtigen Streit mit Rechtsanwälten untereinander im Vorstand. Und wenn sich so eine anarchistische Pogopartei dann wirklich um irgendwelche Machtdinger streitet, dann ist halt vorbei. Das war für mich das wirklich überzeugte APBD-Wähler. Der hat danach gesagt, die wähle ich nie wieder. Weil die sich tatsächlich bekriegt haben um diesen Wer ist Vorstand und sonst wie in so einer Partei, die immer nur saufen, saufen, saufen, saufen ruft.
Und ich verspreche, wenn das bei uns passiert, dass irgendjemand mit Anwalt droht, wenn er nicht irgendwelche Rechte bekommt, dann werde ich nur noch anarchistisch sagen, kein Hedonist mehr. Das ist versprochen.
Okay, dann bietest du natürlich jetzt eine Flanke.
Gerne, gerne. Meine A100.
Aber was, was, was, gut. Ab und mit dir hin und her, was, was bedeutet das? Ich meine, ist das eine, ich unterstelle euch ja auch, sagen wir mal, eine, eine gute Absicht. Ja, also du hast es ja auch schon ausgedrückt. Im Vorgespräch meintest du irgendwie, so was mit Bilder berechnen. Also du willst ja auch eine Änderung erzielen. Oder zumindest wäre es wünschenswert, wenn eine erzielt würde. Kann man darüber diskutieren, wie nachhaltig die dann ist und langfristig. Aber das ist ja schon auch ein Teil des Programms. Jetzt frage ich mich, kann man das bei diesen Spaßparteien auch ähnlich orten? Also ist auch Sonneborns Auftrag in gewisser Hinsicht nachhaltig?
Ich würde sagen, klar, sicher. Der tut seinen Teil dort. Solange es Leute aus Parteien gibt, die so etwas für hochdemokratiegefährdend halten. Ich erinnere mich an eine Freundin, die bei den Grünen arbeitet. Und sie fand das ganz, ganz bedrohlich und demokratiegefährdend. Solange es solche Leute gibt in Parteien, die so etwas so titulieren ist, dann ist das richtig und dann ändert das etwas. Man merkt das ja auch im Augenblick. Es soll ja gar nicht die Staatskrise vertiefen oder das System in sich aushöhlen. Aber Systemänderungen, wie das jetzt im Augenblick zum Beispiel auch mit dem Piraten passiert, oder halt auch mit einer Andersdarstellung, einer Falschdarstellung, einer Richtigstellung von außen, dann ändert das was und das ändert auf Dauer was in der politischen Kommunikation und stärkt eigentlich vielleicht auch ein Stück weit das System, wenn man es denn halten möchte.
Ich glaube nicht, dass, ich glaube, so was wie die Partei ist eigentlich letztlich schon, das nimmt Politiker eine Autorität weg. Und deswegen mögen die das nicht, weil es genau damit spielt und es verarscht sie und es nutzt es auch noch so, dass es Werbespots machen kann, weil die halt eine groß genug Basis haben. Also ich finde, alle versuchen damit Spaß ranzugehen und das auch da auch irgendwie den Spiegel vorzuhalten. Und das finde ich gut. Und es gibt ja verschiedene Versionen. Also ich meine, das ist vorher gesagt etwas, dass im Wahlkampf in Berlin wurden so viele Plakate schön verändert.
Also ich denke auch, in einer Zeit, wo immer wieder Autorität gerade wieder groß geschrieben wird und Eliten wieder gefördert werden, da sozusagen anti-autoritäre Propaganda zu machen, Autoritäten zu brechen, das ist, glaube ich, ja, das ist ein Auftrag. Danke, wir haben verstanden.
Ja, es gibt ja auch in dieser Computer-Internet-Welt gibt es ja auch so eine ähnliche, also ich unterstelle jetzt mal eine Ähnlichkeit, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr damit vertraut seid, der Discordianismus ist ja auch so ein bisschen die Antithese zu der normalen Religionsausübung, in dem es im Wesentlichen versucht erstmal einen ähnlichen Film zu fahren, aber dabei eben komplett anders zu sein. Jeder ist Papst und so, das ist da ja so ein treibendes Ding. Und auch an der Stelle ist es natürlich vor allem der Humor, der so vorangeführt wird, natürlich verborgen hinter einem toternsten Gehabe. Aber eben dann, und das ist ja genau so ein Effekt, man raubt eigentlich diesem ganzen Pfaffentum auf einmal die Aura, weil man es eigentlich als austauschbar und beliebig replizierbar hinstellt und damit ebenso seine Einzigartigkeit nimmt.
Und ich glaube ja immer, wenn ich mir sowas angucke, dass man übrigens auch das Bedürfnis danach befriedigt, vielleicht mal sowas mitzumachen.
Es gibt eine diskordianische Sektion auch, soweit ich weiß.
Ach, der Hedonistischen Internationale. Ah, sehr schön.
Es gibt es auf jeden Fall. Die haben wir irgendwann auch mal. Wir haben sogar ein Soundsystem, glaube ich. Das ist Pflicht, oder? Nein, ich habe keins.
Gehört die Musik dazu, klar. Ob es jetzt immer Techno sein muss, glaube ich nicht. Aber die Bässe haben uns weit getragen.
Weggepasst.
Wie kann denn so... Ich meine, was sind denn so eure... Ihr habt jetzt eine ganze Menge Projekte gemacht. Wir haben sie wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal alle benannt. Was habt ihr denn so... Was kriegt ihr denn so für so ein unmittelbares Echo aus eurem Umfeld, die jetzt selber nicht unbedingt Teil dieser Bewegung sind? Bewegt ihr euch nur unter Leuten, die das total toll finden? Oder habt ihr auch so Lebensbereiche, wo es aneckt oder wo euch Unverständnis oder eben auch überbordendes Verständnis in irgendeiner Form Befreiung oder ähnliches entgegenschlägt? Da merkt man doch auch in gewisser Hinsicht, wo es verfängt und wo man sich vielleicht auch selber fragt, warum merken sie es nicht?
Gibt es glaube ich schon Leute, denen ich das nicht erzählen würde. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich eher so eine…
Also es muss ja jetzt gar nicht mal sein, dass du dich da outest als Teil davon. Ich meine, du wirst ja auch in irgendeiner Form an der Wirkung merken.
Es gibt viele Leute, die das gut finden und da teilweise mit dabei sind. Die würden natürlich nicht sagen, so, du steckst da viel Zeit rein oder so. Aber ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass letztlich dieses bunte und lustig beim Protest und Spaß haben und trotzdem aber auch, also das kann ja auch weichspülermäßig werden, dann lustig und hey und nur Blumen. Dass das letztlich schon, ich meine, wenn man Leute gewinnen will, um eine Revolution zu machen, und das will ich eigentlich schon.
Alle geistige oder wie sieht die aus?
Ja, die läuft im Kopf erstmal ab. Aber dann muss ich ja Leute dazu überzeugen, da mitzumachen und auch irgendwas anbieten, was irgendwie Erfolgsversprechen oder zumindest verspricht, nicht irgendwie schlimm zu werden. Und ich glaube, das ist immer die Kraft von diesem Freude-Ding. Kraft durch Kraft und Freude. Das haben wir noch nie geschafft, eine Nazi-Demo zu verarschen. Das war immer schon die Idee. Endlich.
Das ist schwer zu überspitzen.
Das müssen wir jetzt noch nicht.
Das hat aber Sonneborn gemacht.
Ja, mit dem Fackelmarsch habe ich das Schwein-Ding.
Das war großartig, oder? Also da muss ich auch echt den Hut ziehen. Das fällt mir schwer. Sein Vermächtnis lässt sich ja ohnehin nicht...
Ideen liegen auf der Straße eigentlich.
Aber das ist... Gerade bei den Nazis, ich meine, ihr habt das ja am Anfang auch schon häufiger so gebracht. Das war zumindest ein Teil der Hintergrund-Motivation. Den Nazis mit Spott zu kommen, ist ja schon länger ein Thema. Ich erinnere mich da noch an diesen... Ich weiß nicht, wer hat denn das gemacht? Genau, diese Frontdeutscher Äpfel. Aber dann gab es auch mal dieses Storch-Heiner-Ding. Das ist ja auch in der jüngeren Zeit. Und irgendwann gab es auch mal so einen Fernseh-Spot. Man muss Verständnis haben für die Nazis, die dann irgendwie Fahrstuhlprobleme haben, weil sie mit dem ausgeschnittenen Arm in der Tür stecken bleiben, etc. Ich glaube, das war irgendein Schüler-Projekt. Ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau. Man fragt sich natürlich immer, dann hat man so seinen Spaß daran und findet so, ha ha ha, die sind ja doof. Die Frage ist, ändert das irgendwas? Und ändert das vor allem etwas an der Stelle, wo es vielleicht wichtig wäre? Also dringt dieser Humor in die Leute, von denen ich ja auch mal glatt unterstellen würde, dass 50% ohnehin nur tumme Mitläufer sind, die überhaupt gar nicht realisieren, in welcher Situation sie sind. Dringt das vor? Oder ist dieser Humor an der Stelle nicht nur so eine Selbstversicherung, wie toll Scheiße man das doch alles findet? Und ha ha ha, jetzt haben wir doch auch drüber gelacht.
Also das ist schwierig. Es muss ja nicht immer nur Humor sein. Ich würde sagen, erstens bringt was, denn es schafft ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl bei all denen, die das nicht gut finden und manchmal gar nicht so klar artikulieren können. Das Lachen ist genauso gefährlich wie bei Politikern, vielleicht noch gefährlicher für die Leute, die Hierarchien und Kraft und Gewalt bevorzugen. Also das ist auf jeden Fall einer von den Wegen, dagegen vorzugehen. Das hilft nicht immer. Also mit Humor alleine wirst du den Nazi nicht bekehren. Bekehren wirst du ihn wahrscheinlich sowieso nicht. Aber begegnen. Und dann, ich erinnere mich allerdings auch, vor ein paar Jahren haben wir mal, als wir in Dresden waren, nach der ersten erfolgreichen Blockade dieses Nazi-Aufmarsches in Dresden, haben wir dann spontan im Siegestaumel ein Lied auf die Melodie über den Wolken von Reinhard May geschrieben.
Karen Elliott and the Antifa Swingers. Also das war so eine komplett vermummte, schwarz vermummte, schwarze, also so eine Gruppe, die dann das Lied singt.
Und kann man im Internet auch noch nachgucken. Die schwarz vermummte martialische Truppe hat schunkelnd den Sieg besungen. Und das hat auch wirklich riesen Spaß gemacht. Und da waren die Nazis dann doch so relativ schnell sauer und haben das dann als Impropriate Content auf YouTube gefleckt. Dann war es runter und dann natürlich kamen wir, wo es unser Lied und es kam zurück. Und wir wurden dann in der jungen Welt, ich glaube auch in der Taz erwähnt, den ganzen Text abgedruckt. Und natürlich nützt das was, das ärgert die. Das ist klar. Das war ein Siegessong. Es hat sich dann auf Sicherheit mobilisiert, um im nächsten Jahr wieder Leute dazu zu bringen, da hinzufahren, was natürlich eine wichtige Sache ist. Klar bringt das was. Hat Spaß gemacht. Wir hatten diesen Spaß. Wir konnten uns um ein Siegesgefühl, was ein Siegesgefühl war, was in dem Fall glaube ich auch ein gutes Siegesgefühl ist, Ausdruck verleihen. Und natürlich hat man denen ans Bein gepinkelt. Die sind lächerlich geworden. Wenn man darüber sinkt, dass sie ihr letztes Geld für die Busfahrkarte ausgegeben haben und dann nur der Kälte beim Bahnhof stehen und stehen musste.
Ich glaube, dass du mit diesem Ding trotzdem nicht... Also wir sind Anti-Nazi-Aktionen. Meistens richtest du dich ja nicht an den Nazis. Da gab es letztens diese Sache mit diesem T-Shirt, dann wasche ich es einmal und dann kommt irgendeine Nachricht raus. Das sind so Sachen. Ich glaube, das bringt nicht viel. Und über sie lachen, vielleicht macht es die Leute, die denen nahestehen, geistig, weil das ist ja in Deutschland um die 20%, die irgendwie die gleiche Denke haben, nur hauen die halt nicht Ausländer zusammen. Also die so ein rechtsradikal verfestigtes Weltbild haben, ist halt bis zwischen 12 und 20%. Und diesen Leuten macht es vielleicht schwieriger, das nach außen zu tragen und zu sagen, ja, bin ich auch. Vielleicht verbreitet das so diese Basis von dem, ey, das ist scheiße, Nazi zu sein. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass es denn wirklich ein Nazi richtig überzeugt.
Nein, aber es schafft eine Presse. Das Beispiel mit dem T-Shirt finde ich ganz interessant. Also um es noch kurz zusammenzufassen, die haben es geschafft, T-Shirts zu verkaufen, oder haben sie kostenlos ausgegeben, auf so einem Nazi-Konzert, womit dann halt viele nach Hause gegangen sind. Und wenn man es einmal gewaschen hat, hat es eine Aussage geändert. Und dann war das eben so, hier du kannst auch ein Aussteigerprogramm teilnehmen, etc. Ich frage mich wirklich, wie das angekommen ist. Weil man es natürlich geschafft hat, auf so eine sehr intelligente Art und Weise, der Humor ergibt sich daraus. Aber eigentlich ist es ja ein unglaublicher Hack. Man hat sich mal wirklich darüber Gedanken gemacht, wie schaffen wir es wirklich so direkt in die Schublade zu Hause bei dem kleinen Nazi zu landen und da unsere Botschaft zu platzieren. Zumal man ja davon ausgehen kann, dass üblicherweise diese Botschaften, die man dann eben so sendet, dort eigentlich nie ankommen. Weil man überhaupt gar nicht an demselben Kulturkreis teilnimmt und weil diejenigen sich natürlich entsprechend abgeschirmt haben. Also Intelligenz, sagen wir mal, gehört noch zu Humor dazu. Und viele eurer Aktivitäten, finde ich, zeichnet ja nicht nur der Humor aus, sondern eben auch so eine Hacker-Mentalität, dieses Social-Engineering hier auch mit dem Gutenberg. Wie kommen wir da rein? Was können wir irgendwie für einen Weg wählen, um uns an einer Stelle zu platzieren, wo man uns erstmal gar nicht erwarten würde?
Das ist so. Ich glaube halt, was uns da unterscheidet, dass wir, wenn wir darüber nachgedacht hätten, dort T-Shirts zu platzieren, wie das Exit gemacht hat, und zwar diese NGO, die das gemacht hat, dann denkt man einmal drüber nach und sagt, dann sollen wir jetzt wirklich T-Shirts produzieren, mit viel, viel Geld, die dann beim Waschen denen eine Ausstiegsmöglichkeit geben. Ich finde das eine tolle Aktion. Ich weiß nicht, ob da einer von überzeugt wurde, von den Nazis, die dann ausgestiegen sind. Auf der anderen Seite, man weiß es nicht, ein 16-jähriger Jugendlicher, der auf irgendeinem Nazi-Konzert steht und dann denkt, eigentlich sind die Cleverer. Also ich würde mir wünschen, dass so was Erfolg hat. Ich wäre jetzt nicht der Erste, der sagen würde, das ist aber meine Aktion. Das sind wir, glaube ich, anders gepolt.
Ich glaube, das ist aber eher so eine Spine-Pinkel-Nummer auch. Guck mal, wir haben es in eurer Schublade geschafft. Ich finde bei Nazis zum Beispiel, was die unglaublich schön angreift, und da kann man vielleicht auch einen Aufruf starten, das mal zu machen, ist einfach, ich habe, es gab mal so ein Video von so einem Nazi, und der war so unglaublich peinlich und so besoffen und hat irgendwie so seine, so irgendwelche SA-Dinger bei YouTube gesungen. Und es wäre, glaube ich, toll, ganz viele Videos von peinlichen Nazis irgendwie damit zu fluten und sich über sie lustig zu machen, obwohl es gar keinen echten Sinn, also sie so zu hacken, dass du, dass du so Nazi-Videos machst und ihre Peinlichkeit nach vorne stellst.
Also... Ich finde das schwierig. Also man kann das schwer überspitzen, man sollte es aber eigentlich noch mehr überspitzen und dann so, dass tatsächlich Leute aus ihrem eigenen Umfeld glauben, dass man zum Beispiel eine eigene Nazi-Sektion wäre.
Hier hört auch jetzt eigentlich keiner zu.
Und da könnte man vielleicht noch was machen. Also so überzeugend zu wirken, dass selbst die Anhänger überzeugt sind und dann langsam abzubiegen. Das müsste aber wieder eine Choreografie sein. Da könnte man sowas machen. Über sowas denkt man nach. Aber ehrlich gesagt, hab ich darauf Lust?
Ach nö, das ist...
Mal schauen.
Also eigentlich, also auf mich kommt das auf jeden Fall alles sehr Hacker-mäßig.
Es ist halt Hacken, ohne jemals programmieren zu können. Oder klassische...
Der Hacker sieht das ja eh entkoppelt vom Computer. Das ist zwar ein populäres Instrument, aber beileibe nicht die einzige Disziplin.
Also wir arbeiten ja auch viel mit Computern und natürlich, wir hacken einen sozialen Code. Das ist so.
Die kulturelle Grammatik. Also, das ist auch ein Code, klar. Und ich weiß, okay, da gibt's den Schwachpunkt und die recherchieren nicht gut und da kann ich da rein. Das ist eine Sicherheitslücke. Oder du weißt, okay, 18 Uhr kommt dieses Bild, wenn ich es schaffe, reinzukommen, in die Sicherheit, vorbei am Eingang und da drin bin, kann ich das hacken. Das ist natürlich schon auch...
Ja, so Konfetti um 18 Uhr, das ist einfach so die Anwendung des Exploits.
Wobei ich auf der anderen Seite jetzt auch nicht zu eitel sagen würde, wir sind Hacker. Das ist schon ähnlich von der Vendettät.
Das zeigt, glaube ich, keine Eitelkeit. Das ist ja auch eher ein Bekenntnis.
Aber wenn man sagt, wir sind Hacker, das hört sich immer nach Profis an. Worauf ich hinaus will, ist dabei, dass das eigentlich jeder kann. Mit ein bisschen Feingefühl und ein bisschen Mut. Und dann gesetzt dich hin.
Das ist ja auch das, was die Hacker immer den anderen sagen, die meinen, sie seien. Keine. Also jeder kann ein Hedonist sein. Befreien wir das mal von diesem Hacker-Gedanken. Was ist denn so euer Rat an die da draußen?
Ich glaube, wichtig ist irgendwie einfach, was mit guten Leuten oder Freunden oder einfach was zu starten und einfach ausprobieren. Ich glaube, das Ausprobieren ist einfach auch gut. Einfach mal gucken, was passiert. Hängen alle Leute in einer Straße irgendwie. Hey, mach mal mit. Ich habe das mal gemacht. Da war ich noch kleiner. Und im Krieg macht man alle ein weißes Tuch raus und eine blöde Friedensaktion. Aber das funktioniert. Und dann machen Leute mit. Und ich glaube, dieses Erkennen, dass Leute mitmachen und dass man sich zusammentun kann und was machen kann. Und das einfach damit rumzuspielen auch mal. Und zu sehen, was ich da entfalten kann. Ich finde es immer total schön, wenn das funktioniert.
Was hat denn nicht funktioniert?
Was hat denn nicht funktioniert? Es gibt immer wieder Sachen, die nicht so gut funktionieren. Es gibt Sachen, wo man sich auch uneins ist. Es ist natürlich die, wo das Timing nicht stimmt, wo man sich nicht einig darüber ist, dass das gut funktioniert.
Also hast du ein Beispiel?
Ich habe leider erstaunlicherweise kein Beispiel. Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass wir immer nur Sachen machen, die dann auch funktionieren. Weil wir vorher uns überlegen, lohnt sich das? Und dann hat man nachts zusammen vom Computer verbracht. Und dann klappt das aber. Ich glaube, wir haben mittlerweile einen relativ guten Instinkt entwickelt.
Welche Situationen vermeidet ihr dann erfolgreich? Was sind die Falltüren an der Stelle, auf die man vielleicht treten kann, die ihr so gesehen habt und wo ihr vielleicht gerade knapp vorbei geschippert seid? Gibt es irgendwie No-Gos? Gibt es Sachen, die für euch nicht in Frage kommen, obwohl ihr sie mal erwogen habt, die einfach zu fett sind oder zu viele Opfer?
Es gab ein großes, immer mal als Beispiel, es gab bei dieser Gutenberg-Sache ein großes Plakat. Wir folgen unserem Oberbefehlshaber oder sowas. Infraktur und falsch geschrieben. Solidarität mit dem Oberbefehlshaber. Es gab von den Leuten, die das gemalt haben, den Instinkt, das vor dem Mahnmal für die ermordeten Juden Europas in die Höhe zu strecken. Und das wäre ganz falsch gewesen.
Das könnte aber verhindert werden.
Sehr schnell verhindert werden. Weil da wäre es natürlich, vor dem Brandenburger Tor, hat das im Kontext Gutenberg seinen Sinn, natürlich. Vor ein paar Meter weiter, vor diesem Mahnmal, auf gar keinen Fall. Und das wäre auch vollkommen falsch gewesen. Warum auch? Es hätte einen Sinn verfehlt, es wäre hoch peinlich gewesen, es wäre falsch gewesen. Und da kann man sagen, das ist so eine Falltür, an der sind wir ganz kurz vorbeigeschlittet. Das muss man sich erspüren, wenn man das macht. Das ist für mich eine der Regeln. Da muss man schon, die das Instrumentarium so weit ausgefahren haben, das Sensorium, dass man sowas nicht tut.
Das war eher zufällig, oder?
Auf der anderen Seite möchte ich jetzt nicht den Leuten, die sowas jetzt gehört haben, so was mache ich jetzt auch, da zu viel Skrupel und Bedenken mitgeben. Ich finde eigentlich, was machen und skrupellos sein, in gewisser Weise, die Skrupel überwinden, ist der erste Schritt, um tatsächlich auch selber umzudenken und geistig flexibel zu bleiben. Das finde ich gut.
Ich glaube, man muss sich einfach nicht immer über die... Also wenn ich jetzt einen Twitter-Account fake oder irgendwas mache, nicht denken, oh Gott, dann können die mich anzeigen, und dann kann das passieren, sondern einfach das einfach mal machen. Also ich glaube, das einfach mal machen ist wichtig und sich jetzt nicht klar immer schon nachdenken, was könnte passieren. Ich glaube, ich hätte persönlich Skrupel irgendwie Leute irgendwie mit reinzuziehen in irgendwas, die du eigentlich nicht irgendwelche ganz normalen Leute irgendwie verarschen. Geht ja auch, kann ein super Netz auch machen. Dann geht's aber in Richtung Mobbing. Ich finde, das hätte ich keine Lust drauf.
Ich höre so ein bisschen raus, dass noch eine andere Sache wichtig sein könnte, nämlich was schon erwähnt wurde, nämlich dass man auch so den Mut hat, sich nicht dazu zu bekennen, sondern dieses Offenlassen.
Ganz wichtig.
Weil in dem Moment, wo man diesen Drang hat, auch den Ruhm für etwas einzufahren, das scheint mir doch sehr kontraproduktiv zu sein, weil man dann eben schnell zwängen...
Das wird ganz schnell, wenn die Leute Erfolg gehabt haben mit so einer Aktion, wird das ganz schnell vergessen. Die Leute wollen natürlich dann sozusagen auch die Anerkennung dafür. Und ich kann das auch verstehen. Aber es ist tatsächlich das Schönste, sich nicht zu kennen und es einfach stehen zu lassen. Wie bei der FDP-Aktion, es wäre einfach schön gewesen, wenn da gejubelt würde und wilde Interviews. Und man wäre dann verschwunden. Das wäre künstlerisch schön gewesen schon fast. Wo man halt aber sagt, toll. Natürlich sind wir alle darauf geeicht, dass man sich das abholen will, die Anerkennung. Und dass man sagen will, guck mal, hier bin ich. Und das war toll. Aber das wäre falsch im Sinne des Erfinders. Keine Ahnung.
Ja, also ich glaube, es gibt so ein ehrenes Prinzip in der Hedonistischen Internationale. Und es hat noch bisher niemand, keine einzige Sektion, das dagegen verstoßen. Und das steht aber nirgendwo. Und es wird nie mit Klarnamen irgendwas gemacht. Und dann spricht Andi Gewehr aus Greifswald und der Nächste. Und die heißen immer anders. Und die tauschen die Namen. Und niemand sagt, ich mit meinem Namen habe das gemacht. Und kann mich da profilieren oder so ein Ding machen.
Ich kann ja kein Popstar sein. Das ist ja auch irgendwie nicht bekannt.
Sondern wenn, dann geht dieser Ruhm an die Hedonistische Internationale, die ja eine Idee ist und die andere dann auch wieder nutzen können. Und es geht aber nicht. Ich kann das nicht privatisieren. Und das finde ich total gut, dass das nicht geht.
Es gibt da auch eine ganz interessante Pseudonym-Kultur. Weil da werden verschiedene Pseudonyme verwendet, die auch teilweise schon so eine Geschichte und eine eigene Vergangenheit als Pseudonym haben.
Ja, aber da muss man auch aufpassen, dass das nicht zu häufig auf dieselbe Person verwendet wird. Also natürlich ist es schön, jemanden Erich Picour zu nennen, wenn man sich Erich Picour zu nennen oder Lola Ferrami.
Noch schöner ist es natürlich, wenn Erich Picour als Pressesprecher in der Tat redet, weil der Name E-Picour und Erik Picour. Also man muss mit Journalisten, den darf man nie sagen, das ist ein Pseudonym, weil sie dann sagen, ja, dessen Name anders ist, viel besser ist, dem gar nicht zu sagen. Also wie, ich bin Alexander Müller, und dann schreiben die Alexander Müller. Und gar nicht, das jemals in Zweifel zu ziehen, weil es ist eh egal, wie der Name ist. Und hinten dran steht immer, Name geändert, ist immer so, ist genau wie verpixelte Gesichter, ist ja auch so ein Problem. Bei Aktionen muss ja nicht das Gesicht da sein, macht aber, sieht halt immer so hässlich aus.
Abgesehen davon vermeidet man dadurch dann irgendwann, dass man sich mit Anwälten behargt und dass einige Leute den Ruhm ganz auf sich ziehen wollen. Also all das vermeidet man einfach damit, dass man darauf verzichtet, Ruhm zu werden.
Es ist auch sicherer. Ich meine, der Pseudonym ist einfach, wenn da immer verschiedene Leute unter verschiedenen Namen auftreten, ist es einfach schwieriger von außen zu sehen, wer eigentlich irgendwas veranstaltet.
Schon eine kleine Geheimgesellschaft. Ihr seid doch Teil des Systems. Aber nicht erfolgreich.
Also wir würden uns ja gerne mal freuen, wenn wir so richtig, wir hatten schon ganz am Anfang so Kritiker gehabt, die sagten, ihr seid doch Teil des Spektakels. Und eigentlich unterstützt ihr das nur. Diese Kritiker wollen wir eigentlich auch gerne mal auf den Kongress einladen.
Es sind alle nicht gekommen, die Kritiker. Andere sagen, ihr seid Sozialdemokraten und sonst wie. Und die kommen nie. Das wäre echt schön, wenn die mal kommen und sagen, ey, warum? Ist euer Konzept nicht gut? Oder warum seid ihr Reformisten? Oder was auch immer. Das ist natürlich auch immer so eine komische linke Lager.
Aber ich vermute mal, die Vorträge auf dem Kongress, die werden nicht aufgezeichnet, oder? Manche.
Gibt's, aber eigentlich eher nicht.
Kommt drauf an, wer spricht.
Also es mag Spuren im Netz geben.
Es mag Spuren im Netz geben. Ja, wir müssen mal gucken, dass es nicht zu viele sind. Aber es gibt es schon manchmal. Und ich glaube, da kommt demnächst noch was. Da gibt es noch so Aufzeichnungen, die schlummern noch bei uns.
Ein halbes Jahr später. Wir sind relativ schnell mit der Veröffentlichung.
Jetzt wird es vielleicht Winterpause machen.
Ja, was haben wir denn noch vergessen?
Überlegt gerade.
Fehlt euch noch etwas, was diese Idee ausmacht? Gibt es denn unerreichte Ziele? Denken wir überhaupt zu weit?
Der Karl würde jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen, das unerreichte Ziel ist die Revolution. Ich bin weniger messianisch unterwegs, aber ich glaube, das zeichnet uns auch aus, die Revolution kommt oder auch nicht. Ich glaube auf jeden Fall, dass es Veränderungen gibt, aber die Revolution gibt, weiß ich nicht. Er will sie gerne, ich nicht, und andere wollen wieder was ganz anderes.
Das ist auch das Schöne, es ist diffus, aber es einigt sich, dass was sich ändern muss. Ich weiß nicht, dafür bin ich zu alt, um zu glauben, dass die Revolution vor der Tür steht. Ich weiß nicht, aber ich glaube da schon dran.
Ich beobachte gerade diese Occupy-Leute und ähnliche Sachen. Das kommt mir unglaublich bekannt vor, wenn ich uns so selber angucke, mit dem, was wir gemacht haben. Ich finde das auch total gut, ist das gleich jetzt die Revolution. Wollen die wirklich den Umsturz nehmen, wollen die nicht, aber die sind diffus und beängstigend gut organisiert. Man kann kaum jemanden ansprechen, die sprechen in Köhren vor dem Reichstag Sachen nach, kämpfen in Frankfurt vor der Börse oder vor der Deutschen Bank. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, sowas finde ich natürlich toll. Eigentlich ist das genau das. Das sind nicht nur wir, die da in einer gewissen Art denken und ticken, sondern das ist tatsächlich was, was die 99% ausmacht. Das ist ein Zeitgeist, der da entsteht, glaube ich.
Ein ähnliches Prinzip mit diesem, es gibt irgendwie eine Idee und dann kann ich mich da anonym ran. Also diese Clustern. Auch von der Idee.
Ja, ich sehe da eine ganze Menge Parallelen, zumal es ja jetzt auch nicht humorbefreit ist. Auch die Anonymous-Aktionen, auch wenn sie so ein bia-ernstes Ziel haben. Ich meine, losging das Ganze ja mit dem Scientology-Protest, ausgelöst durch diesen Versuch, Dinge der Öffentlichkeit vorzuenthalten. Dieses absurde Video von Tom Cruise, wo er da so daher geredet hat über die Ziele von Scientology und was denn so toll daran wäre. Und das Internet hat ja an der Stelle Leute auch zusammengebracht und sich organisieren lassen, die man vielleicht am Anfang vor allem mit 15-jährigen Teenager mit viel zu viel Zeit. Mittlerweile, denke ich, geht es schon sehr viel weiter. Hat es eben auch wiederum durch diese neuartigen Kommunikationsformen ermöglicht, da eine Protestkultur zu entwickeln, die es in dieser Form vorher gar nicht geben konnte. Mit interessanten Auswirkungen. Also der Scientology-Prozess ist noch sehr in sich selbst stecken geblieben, vielleicht falsch gesagt, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt so eine große Änderung gebracht hat. Aber diese Occupy-Bewegung wiederum hat zumindest diesen viralen Charakter. Auf einmal ist es möglich, Protestarten zu erfinden und bittend von Tagen über diesen Planeten zu streuen. Mit noch unklarem Ausgang. Ich denke nicht, dass jetzt morgen alle Banken schließen werden. Auch an der Stelle steckt dieser schrittweise Sinneswandel, der ermöglicht wird dadurch, durchaus mit drin.
Ja, ich glaube, sich anders zu organisieren zu können und auch das Ganze nicht...
Und auch fürs Ganze zu stehen. Keinen Sprecher zu haben und so ist ja auch ähnlich. Diese Guy Fawkes Maske aus diesem Film, so als das Symbol, dass ich trete als Individuum zurück und bin einfach nur ein Teil einer Bewegung.
Ohne, dass es meine Person...
Also was mich bei Anonymos manchmal bei allem Respekt ein bisschen stört, ist, dass wir sich halt gerne eben als diese Helden auch verkaufen. Und das finde ich ein bisschen... Das finde ich manchmal ein bisschen aufgesetzt. Wir sind die anonymen Helden im Hintergrund. Ich will kein Held sein. Ich will kein Held sein. Ich habe Spaß an der Freude politisch aktiv zu sein. Eigentlich im normalen Leben bin ich eigentlich auch ein Bürger dieses Staates. Und genau deswegen mache ich genau diesen Blödsinn, aber auch genau deswegen. Und ich habe keine Verschwörungsideologien im Kopf, sondern ich glaube, man kann viel erreichen und man muss viel tun. Aber ja, trotzdem anonymus, super, haut rein.
Generell ist es doch super, wenn Leute was machen. Das ist natürlich sehr allgemein, aber ich finde, wenn sich jetzt keine Ahnung, wer da dahinter steckt und was für Leute das sind, aber es ist doch super.
Es ist jeder, es ist ein bisschen wie bei euch. Man kann ja jederzeit auch anonymus sein.
Ich stand auch schon mal vor so einem...
Verlasst uns in Anonymus hängen.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch so interessant. Ich habe schon am Anfang auch gedacht, wo wir jetzt auch so viel über Sicherheitslücken von anderen Organisationen geredet haben, eigentlich habt ihr das ja auch. In dem Moment, wo jeder HI sein kann, könnte ja irgendwas passieren, ist bloß irgendwie noch nicht passiert, könnte aber passieren. Und das ist bei Anonymous auch so, aber gerade wahrscheinlich, weil das so ist, passiert das nicht.
Das ist komisch, wenn ich nur eine Idee habe und ich kann mich spontan und auch temporär anschließen, das ist ja leicht hackbar.
Aber trotzdem gilt nur das als authentisch Teil, was eben auch authentisch genug ist, dass es auch wirklich dazu passt.
Und die Leute, alle Sektionen, die ich getroffen hatte, waren irgendwie nette, lustige, coole Leute. Das war irgendwie das Komische, dass du merkst, wir können miteinander was machen. Bei diesem Kongress ist das total abgefahren, dass sich da halt auch bestimmte Leute so treffen.
Querdenker, Spinner, Freaks, hohe Freak-Dichte, das muss man auch einfach zugeben. Also auch für mich manchmal, weil ich denke, meine Güte, aber auf jeden Fall auch Mut zu Andersartigkeit tatsächlich, und ich glaube, das wird unterschätzt mittlerweile. Wir reden alle über den Individualismus, aber dieser Mut zu Andersartigkeit wird uns eigentlich gerade deutlich aberzogen auf verschiedensten Wegen. Und das zu fördern bzw. sich da zu treffen und sich gegenseitig auch zu verstärken, das finde ich mal gut. Das ist nicht nur defensiv, sondern auch von offensiv.
Aber mal gucken, ob mal endlich die Nazis uns hacken, aber ich glaube es ja nicht.
Da fällt ihm wahrscheinlich dann doch der Humor.
Ja, ich glaube, das ging aber nicht hin. Die National-Hedonistische Station.
Die National-Hedonistische Station! Endlich!
Wir haben unsere Fahne wiedergefunden.
Da haben wir es, glaube ich, oder? Das war ein schöner Einblick in eine Art und Weise, über die Realität sich Gedanken zu machen.
Ja, danke, hat Freude bereitet.
Ja, das hat mir auf jeden Fall schon immer sehr am Herzen gelegen, das hier mal einzubringen bei CRE und ich finde es ganz gut, dass ich jetzt zu einem angenehmen Thema hier auch meine Serie fortsetzen kann, auch das motiviert. Und Mut zu anderer Artigkeit, nichts anderes, versuche ich hier auch regelmäßig unter Folg zu bringen, weil das ist einfach auch wichtig. Also ich meine, dieser ganze Konformitäts-Scheiß, der kann mir echt gestohlen bleiben.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn jemand Spaß daran hat, jetzt ganz konform zu sein, ich möchte ihn nicht fürter haben.
Na klar, aber ich meine, viele leiden auch. Das ist auch so ein Jugendproblem. Man ist einfach umgeben von, du musst so sein, du musst so sein, alle anderen sind doch auch so, warum bist du denn nicht so? Und dann leidet man da drunter und dann denkt man immer so, Gott, ich bin anders und Gott, ich bin furchtbar. Ich kann echt nur sagen, wenn du das entdeckt hast, dass du da auch, dass du einfach anders sein kannst, dann hast du wahrscheinlich schon mal den wichtigsten Schritt gemacht. Gratulation. Now move on.
Das wird so anders sein als eine Jugendbewegung, ne? Das sind wir nicht.
Na ja, aber ich finde das hat sehr Jugendlichen erfrischenden, also Jugendlichsein im besten Sinne, ne? Erfrischend.
So kann ich das annehmen.
Danke.
Von einem Berufsjugendlichen.
Kannst du das annehmen. Okay, dann machen wir hier mal Schluss. Abdullah, Karl, vielen Dank, das war die Hedonistische Internationale und das war die 185. Ausgabe von CRE. Und hier geht es bald wieder weiter. Ich weiß, das sage ich immer, aber es ist auch so. Ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören und sage tschüss und bis bald.